Hallo, hallo, orgu, heute hat sich auf Twitter einer drüber lustig gemacht, dass ich mit
fast 40 in Twitch Emotes spreche, stellt euch das mal vor, keck wait, kann er nicht
sein, gar nicht was der hat, steht doch jedem frei herunter 40 in Twitch Emotes zu sprechen,
finde das sollte eigentlich komplett normal sein, ey ich mein Leute, was heute alles normal ist,
da gehts doch in Twitch Emotes sprechen noch das kleinste Problem, oder? Ich weiß gar nicht,
was mich das überhaupt interessiert. Vorti, du bist der erste, ja wie keck wait, ja richtiges
keck wait, hyper keck wait, warum gibt es eigentlich nur keck wait und nicht keckle wait, na gut,
wie soll keckle wait bitte schön aussehen, ergibt keinen Sinn, ja ne, moin, so siehts aus,
tja, ihr wart ja noch nicht da, ich sag's jetzt nochmal, stellt euch das mal vor,
könnt ihr euch das vorstellen, es hat sich heute einer auf Twitter lustig gemacht, dass ich mit
fast 40 Jahren noch in Twitch Emotes spreche, ich hab ihn dann bloß gefragt, was ist das Problem,
keck wait, es steht jedem frei herunter 40 in Twitch Emotes zu sprechen, es sollte prinzipiell
eigentlich jeder in Twitch Emotes sprechen, bloß die Oberkecks sprechen in Twitch Emotes,
also quasi so 99,9999% der Weltbevölkerung sprechen nicht in Twitch Emotes, aber das heißt ja nicht,
ob das gut oder schlecht ist in Twitch Emotes zu sprechen, denn wann ich Windows 11 habe,
seitdem ich meinen neuen Rechner verwende, übrigens ich hab eine Sponsoring Anfrage,
jetzt halten euch mal fest, ich hab eine Sponsoring Anfrage bekommen von Geizhals,
hab ich heute schon weitergeleitet, werden wir uns auch kümmern, aber ich hab eine Sponsoring
Anfrage bekommen von Geizhals und die haben wohl irgendein neues RefLink Programm und ich
glaube, also je nachdem wie die Konditionen sind, werde ich das machen, weil ich plane eh meine ganzen
RefLinks mal ein bisschen zu erneuern, weil, naja, ich hab aktuell so gut wie keine RefLinks,
was zweite ist Amazon bezahlt die letzten Jahre über immer weniger, ganz am Anfang kann ich mich
noch dran erinnern, 2010, 2011 rum, da war das noch gestaffelt nach Verkäufen und du hast richtig
viel, du hast teilweise 7-8% oder so was von Verkäufen abgekriegt auf Amazon, das war richtig
krass, ich hatte teilweise am Ende des Monats irgendwie 1000-1500 Euro und noch was, obwohl ich
damals gar nicht viel gespammt habe, die Links, rein Amazon-Links und das wurde immer weniger
kontinuierlich die letzten Jahre über und deswegen, also vielleicht mache ich tatsächlich Geizhals,
Geizhals-RefLinks, ich frag mich ja, wie sich das finanziert, ich meine, Geizhals bekommt Geld für
das Weiterleiten von Besuchern auf die Seite und ein Teil davon bekommt man dann, wenn man auf
Geizhals weiterleitet, das ist auch schon ein richtig High-Fed-Finanzierungsmodell. Laut, oder?
Ne, das ist kein RefLink, aber sowas genau, genau sowas wird dann in Zukunft wahrscheinlich
ein RefLink sein, ich meine, warum nicht? So eigentlich ganz gut, oder? Wie viele Tabs ich aufwärme,
ja, Moment mal, das reicht ja noch gar nicht, ich habe hier Tabs auf, ich habe da Tabs auf und ich
habe, wenn ich die, ach Mist, die VM, ja, die VM habe ich nicht umgezogen bis jetzt, wisst ihr,
warum ich die VM nicht umgezogen habe? Weil ich faul as fuck bin. Eigentlich wollte ich mit euch
heute eine Runde Progress Stream machen, es gibt nämlich was, was mir schon die ganze Zeit so
vorschwebt, was ich mal ausprobieren will und da ist mir aufgefallen, ich habe mir meine VM gar
nicht umgezogen, das heißt wir können gar kein Progress Streams machen. Sieh was ich bauen will,
und zwar, ich möchte einen Custom Prometheus Nordexporter bauen, und zwar für das Ablaufen
von registrierten Domains. Wolltest du die VM nicht auch irgendwann neu machen? Korrekt.
Wollte ich, das ist richtig, dass ich das, ich wollte viel, ich wollte viel machen. Aber ich
habe davon nicht so viel gemacht. Also das wird wahrscheinlich demnächst auch noch anstehen,
mal gucken, jetzt wird es, ich wollte die, wie gesagt, schon wirklich lange erneuern,
badabummdings, danke schön für den Sub. Ich wollte die ja schon lange mal erneuern,
auch mal ein paar neue Sachen ausprobieren, wie so Starship als Kommandozeilenprompt und so was.
Zumindest was ich, was ich progress technisch ausprobieren will, ist folgendes, möchte ein
Custom Prometheus Exporter bauen für das Expiren von Domains. Ich meine nicht Zertifikate oder sowas,
ich meine, dass die Domains Expiren, weil wenn man sich Domains geholt hat, Kekkelomegalul.net
oder sowas, dann laufen die ja ab. Und ich habe meine Domains, glaube ich, bei irgendwie vier oder
fünf verschiedenen. Ich habe, ich habe, ich habe bei Porkbun was, bei Namesilo, richtig alter,
alter Schrott, ja, die Seite sackt auch total. Namecheap. Ich habe noch eine Domain bei Nitrado,
Alter. Gibt es die überhaupt noch? Ja gut, die muss ich ja noch geben. Bei Cloudflare,
ja, und das wollte ich eigentlich alles mal ordentlich überwachen und es gibt irgendwie
nichts richtiges dafür. Richtig, richtig, ja genau. Und ich habe mir überlegt, also man kann
theoretisch Hures abfragen machen und hoffen, dass es drinne steht, aber bei den meisten Domains
steht das ja gar nicht mehr drinne. Das müsste man halt so bauen, dass man möglichst viele
Registrar-APs unterstützt, sofern die APs haben. Aber so viele gibt es da ja nicht. Lass mal,
lass mal zehn, zehn Plugins bauen, also zehn, zehn Registrare unterstützen, da hast du eigentlich
schon das meiste. Oder lass mal 15, dann hast du eigentlich schon das meiste. Es muss halt einfach
erweiterbar sein, dass man relativ easy noch einen weiteren reinkriegt. Aber es gibt sowas
nicht in der Richtung. Es gibt eine PAP-Software, die macht das, aber die unterstützt auch nur
eine Handvoll an Registrern. Ja, sowas in der Richtung. Ja, und das kann ich halt nur machen,
wenn ich die VM umgezogen habe, so wird das nichts. Was kann man als Physik, was kann man
als Physik, als Berufseinsteiger so verlangen? Das hängt davon ab, in welcher Region du bist.
Alter, ich habe ein ganz nerviges Haar hier gerade an der Seite hängen. Das hängt davon ab, in welcher
Branche du bist, in welcher Region du bist und natürlich irgendwo letztendlich auch was du kannst.
Bist du übernommen oder suchst du dir einen neuen Job? Das ist auch immer ganz wichtig, weil ich
habe zumindest den Eindruck, ich kann euch das jetzt nicht belegen irgendwie an Zahlen oder so,
aber ich habe den Eindruck, dass Leute, die von ihrem Ausbildungsbetrieb übernommen werden,
tendenziell etwas weniger bekommen als welche, die sich gleich nach der Ausbildung was Neues
suchen. Wobei es auch schwierig sein kann, sich direkt nach der Ausbildung was Neues zu suchen,
weil so wirkliche Belege für man hat es voll drauf, hat man ja nicht. Aber die sind heute
nicht wählerisch und ich denke, viele kommen einem da auch ein bisschen entgegen. Und wenn
man die im Vorstellungsgericht überzeugt und halt auch ein bisschen was kann und nicht einfach nur
labert, dann geht das auch als Berufseinsteiger. Gut, was man jetzt so verlangen kann, ehrlich
gesagt keine Ahnung. Ich kann dir sagen, also doch, wir können uns das irgendwie ein bisschen
zusammenreimen. Also ich kann dir sagen, was ich bekommen habe, aber das ist 15 Jahre her. Also was
ich bekommen habe, war 33.500, wenn ich nicht ganz falsch liege, doch, ich glaube 33.500,
habe ich damals bekommen noch beim Internet Provider als Einstiegsgehalt direkt nach der
Ausbildung. So, mittlerweile sollte es natürlich auch in Anbetracht der Inflationsrate in letzter
Zeit und auch, dass da einfach schlicht nach 15 Jahre dazwischen gelegen haben, sollte natürlich
schon ein bisschen mehr bei rumkommen. Also würde ich mal sagen, also 40k im Jahr sollte es schon
sein. Eher mehr, aber unter 40k ist vielleicht dann doch ein bisschen wenig, vor allem auch
gerade im Anbetracht der Tatsache, dass die Leute aktuell wie verrückt IT Leute suchen. Egal, wo du
hinguckst, die springen im Dreieck, die suchen alle, wie verrückt IT Leute. Bei mir auf der Arbeit,
by the way, kann ich euch jetzt auch nochmal erzählen, geht übrigens weiter. Ich habe jetzt
noch von drei anderen Leuten gehört, die entweder auch weg sind oder dann zum 31.6. weg sind. Also
da rennen sie alle, da rennen sie alle ein bisschen weg. Nee, das ist auf jeden Fall nicht
zu viel, das ist eher noch ein bisschen zu wenig. Also guckt doch mal, was schreibt er denn hier?
2900 Euro pro, also das kannst du mal 12 rechnen, das klingt jetzt aber nicht so wahnsinnig, aber
nicht so wahnsinnig dicke. Na, das ist ein bisschen wenig. Also das muss ich sagen, das wäre mir
tatsächlich ein bisschen wenig, weil, wie gesagt, überlegt euch mal, ich habe 33.500 Euro bekommen,
als mein allerersteres Gehalt, als ich damals beim Provider direkt nach der Ausbildung angefangen
habe. So, und das sind 15 Jahre später. 15 Jahre später sollte es dann doch ein bisschen mehr als
Einstiegsgehalt geben, als rund 1000 Euro mehr als bei mir damals. Klar, das war bei mir damals auch
mit Niederlassung in Frankfurt und alles insgesamt, aber trotzdem, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen
wenig. Also 40k würde ich schon durchaus sagen, aber die sollen schon mal gucken. Was ich jetzt
auch gemerkt habe, was wichtig ist, kann ich jetzt an der Stelle auch nochmal sagen, was
tatsächlich ganz wichtig ist, was ich so bis jetzt zu dem, wo ich jetzt den Job gewechselt habe,
für alle, die es noch nicht mitbekommen haben, also ich habe Ende letzten Jahres noch den neuen
Vertrag unterschrieben und meinen alten Job gekündigt. Also, ab 1.4. geht es dann los.
Und fuck, jetzt habe ich vergessen, was ich sagen wollte. Ich weiß, es ist der Boomer Brain. Ich darf
nicht mehr so viel zwischendurch einschieben. Ach ja, genau, also was den-to-dev-dangisch für den
Sub, also was auch wichtig ist, dass man einen gewissen Plan macht mit seinem Chef oder mit seinem
Personaltyp, aber meistens halt mit seinem Chef. Meistens ist ja Personalplanung und so und Chef
für Fachleger das gleiche. Dass man mit seinem Chef einen Plan macht, also sprich, dass man
Perspektiven und Entwicklungsmöglichkeiten bespricht über die nächsten 1-2 Jahre. Weil
ansonsten endet das so, wie ich das bei ganz vielen Leuten gesehen habe, dass jedes Mal,
wenn es ums Thema geht, mehr Geld heißt immer, ah, das ist ganz schlecht gerade. Als war gerade
Corona. Oh, jetzt ist nach Corona. Ah, da ist jetzt auch ganz, ganz schlimm Inflation. Ah,
das ist ganz furchtbar schlecht. Also tatsächlich, also in so einem Perspektivenplan, so was planen
wir für die nächsten 1-2 Jahre plus, dass es dann alles ein bisschen verbindlicher ist,
das finde ich tatsächlich jetzt so im Nachhinein wichtig, weil das gab es im Vorfeld bei mir nicht.
Und das wäre wahrscheinlich echt nicht schlecht gewesen. Hätte ich die mal schon
jahrelang mehr genervt, hätte ich wahrscheinlich früher ein bisschen mehr gekriegt. Naja,
aber wie gesagt, mehr kann ich dazu nicht sagen. Weißt du, was man als Absolvent fordern kann?
DevOps Engineer Bachelor, hab gehört. Moment, man kann ein Bachelor in DevOps machen?
Nee, oder? Nee, du hast IT studiert, du hast Informatik studiert und willst jetzt als DevOps
Engineer anfangen, oder? Habt was gehört von 3K im Monat? Was meine ich wenigstens? Ja,
ganz ehrlich. Also 3K, das sind ja im Endeffekt dann auch nicht viel mehr als das, was wir gerade
ausgerechnet haben. Also als Einstiegsgehalt finde ich das durchaus in Ordnung. Das kann man,
also das ist, wenn man jetzt bei 3100, man muss halt immer, man muss halt fragen, ist es 12
Monatsgelder, 13 Monatsgelder, 14 Monatsgelder? Deswegen finde ich es immer deutlich sinnvoller,
wenn man das im Jahr angibt, weil im Jahr angegeben ist es egal, ob das jetzt bla bla bla 13 mit Bonus
14, 14,5 plus minus Bonus, im Jahr weiß der halt Bescheid. Also wenn man das mal 12 rechnet,
sind wir hier bei so was, das ist 37.000, das kann man durchaus machen als Einstiegsgehalt,
also 3100. Auch mit einem Abschluss, aber es muss dann halt schon gewisse Perspektiven geben,
weil der Wahnsinn ist es jetzt nicht. Muss mich auch erstmal dran gewöhnen,
an das neue, an den neuen Betrag. Gibt es einen Unterschied bei den verschiedenen FISIs,
bei den unterschiedlichen Fachinformatikern? Das eine hat eher Schwerpunkt Netzwerk und
hat das andere Daten, ich kenne die neuen gar nicht, weiß es gar nicht, keine Ahnung. Ich kenne die
neuen, es gibt zwei neue Fachinformatiker. Also Fachinformatiker Systemintegration hat
eher Schwerpunkt Richtung Server, Betriebssysteme, Netzwerk und solche Geschichten und Anwendungsentwickler
hat natürlich eher Schwerpunkt Richtung Softwareentwicklung, aber das dürfte
eigentlich relativ offensichtlich sein anhand schon des Namens.
Bekommst du jetzt mehr oder weniger? Ich bekomme jetzt mehr. Ich mache da im nächsten Mal ein
Video zu, aber ich habe es euch ja letztens schon erzählt und weil das die Leute immer so interessiert,
werde ich jetzt einfach noch mal ganz kurz umreißen. Also ich kann es euch nicht exakt sagen,
ich bin mir auch nicht sicher, inwieweit die Bonusberechnung irgendwie da nicht weiter
erzählt werden soll, aber ich kann es euch zumindest unterm Strich sagen. Natürlich vor
Ende der Probezeit ab dem ersten Monat. Ich schaffe es doch nicht irgendwie die ersten paar
Monate umsonst, weil Probezeit ist. Ich kann es ja auch übertreiben. Ne, schon am ersten Tag,
ab dem ersten Monat. Also was ich jetzt habe ist, ich habe 92.000 Euro im Vertrag stehen und dazu
kommt der Bonus errechnet sich aus, wie gut geht es der Firma, oder wie gut es ging dieses
Jahr der Firma, wie gut geht es der Abteilung und wie gut war ich. Und dann kommt noch mal obendrauf
für Samstagseinsätze und dass man ein Firmenhandy bei sich liegen hat daheim auch noch mal was,
was am Ende dann wahrscheinlich irgendwas um 105 bis 110k macht, was im Vergleich zu jetzt schon
ein ordentlicher Sprung ist. Ja Moment, Moment, Moment, das ist auf fünf Tage gerechnet,
das ist auf fünf Tage gerechnet, das ist auf fünf Tage gerechnet. Das sage ich gar nicht dabei,
weil das eigentlich der Standard ist, das ist alles auf fünf Tage gerechnet. Was dann am Ende
so irgendwas um 105 und 110 oder je nachdem. Ich kann es euch wirklich genau erst sagen,
wenn das erste Jahr dort rum ist, irgendwie sowas in dem Dreh rausläuft und ich auch genau erst
mal gecheckt habe, wie sich das mit dem Bonus genau berechnet. Sie haben mir das zwar erklärt,
aber ganz ehrlich so richtig, so richtig geistig verarbeitet habe ich es noch nicht. Und ja,
das Ganze kann man jetzt quasi mal 0,8 rechnen und dann wisst ihr, was ich verdiene, weil ich
arbeite nur vier Tage die Woche. Moin, Chain-Lore auch am Start. Aja, ja. Und das ist auch so was,
wo ich sagen würde, hey, das kann man durchaus nach einer Weile Berufserfahrung anpeilen,
mein klar. Ich habe jetzt natürlich Glück. Es ist Frankfurt, es ist Banken und die suchen alle
händeringen Leute. Ja, das ist klar, dass ich da, dass ich da ganz gut habe. Aber man sollte
sich nicht unter Wert verkaufen. Gerade in der heutigen Zeit. Die sagen dir alle. Ich kann euch
ja ich kann euch ja gleich mal die eine Story erzählen. Die sagen ja alle. Es geht nicht mehr.
So nach dem Motto, so ab so und so viel ist kritisch und ach ja und das ist nicht nicht
marktüblich. Das ist doch scheiß egal, was marktüblich ist. Was marktüblich ist entscheidet
aktuell ihr. Nicht die, die sich da irgendwas ausdenken, weil die, die sich was ausdenken
und nicht genug bezahlen wollen oder das nicht attraktiv genug ist, die finden schlicht und
ergreifend keine Leute. Ihr entscheidet das mit, was marktüblich ist, also nicht was da
irgendwelche Recruiter oder irgendwelche anderen Leute erzählen. Und die müssen heutzutage. Die
haben im Prinzip drei Möglichkeiten. Ich weiß, wir gucken die ganze Zeit auf den Chat. Aber
damit muss ich jetzt einfach nochmal erzählen. Also Unternehmen haben doch realistisch betrachtet,
haben die doch eigentlich nur drei Möglichkeiten, was sie machen können, um Leute zu bekommen.
Entweder die einfachste Variante, aber nicht die billigste ist, die die kacken die Leute zu
mit Geld. So nach dem Motto, ey, wir wissen, unser Job ist nicht sonderlich attraktiv. Wir
sind eigentlich auch ein Kackladen und ja, so normal kommt eigentlich keiner zu uns, aber wir
kacken dich so mit Geld zu, dass du zu uns kommst. Das ist eine Möglichkeit, das kann man machen.
Das werden sicherlich auch einige machen. Das können sich allerdings nicht alle leisten. Das
ist die erste Möglichkeit. Die können einfach unglaublich viel Geld bieten und sonst nichts
ändern. Können sie machen, finden sie auch Leute. Das nächste ist, sie können sagen,
hey, wir versuchen vielleicht ein bisschen was am Geld zu machen, aber wir versuchen halt
attraktiver zu sein von Homeoffice Möglichkeiten bis Job Tickets, bis Kantine, bis Betriebssystem
Auswahl, ergonomische Sitzplätze, Firmenhandy, Firmenauto, Kinderbetreuung, was auch immer.
Es gibt ja alle möglichen Sachen. Das kann man natürlich auch machen. Da sagen sicherlich auch
viele, vor allem wenn das was ist, was räumlich auch noch ein bisschen näher ist, sagen bestimmt
auch viele, ja, okay, überzeugt mich, mache ich. Dann müssen sie halt nicht ganz so sehr in die
Tasche greifen, wenn sie das machen. Oder, und das ist die dritte Variante, und die dritte Variante
wählen wahrscheinlich tatsächlich recht viele Unternehmen, und zwar, das ist, ihre Ansprüche
drastisch runterzuschrauben. Also quasi, wenn man, das sehe ich aktuell, da wo ich arbeite gerade,
also quasi, wenn man sagt, okay, man hat ja eigentlich eine klassische Server-System-Administrator-Stelle,
der soll nach Möglichkeiten Erfahrungen haben mit, keine Ahnung, Ubuntu, Red Hat, Engine X,
MySQL, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, sondern könnte man jetzt sagen, okay, wir nehmen einfach jeden
da hergelaufenen, der das für die Kohle macht. Und das sehe ich aktuell so ein bisschen dort wo
ich arbeite. Die haben wirklich Probleme Leute zu bekommen, und was da teilweise jetzt schon
angeschafft wird, ist halt, ich weiß nicht, ich habe da so meine Zweifel an den Fähigkeiten der
Leute, die sie da finden. Also die drei Möglichkeiten sehe ich so, was Unternehmen machen können. Also
entweder massig mehr Geld, sich selbst attraktiver machen oder ihre Ansprüche drastisch runterschrauben.
Das heißt, man darf sich nicht, das war irgendwie Antwort hier oben drauf, oder? Genau. Das heißt,
man darf sich nicht unter Wert verkaufen. Also es ist immer gut, rumzugucken, was es gibt. Ich selbst
gucke mich jetzt auch schon seit einer ganzen Weile um. So wirklich ernst geworden ist es auch
wirklich erst gegen zwei jahreshälfte letztes Jahr. Weil dort haben sie, sind sie ja komplett,
komplett, haben sie ja komplett bescheuertes Zeug gemacht, was was Homeoffice angeht. Ich weiß
nicht, ob ich euch das schon mal erzählt habe. Also letztes Jahr haben sie bei uns folgendes,
ich muss mal kurz hier Fenster ein bisschen verschieben auf der anderen Seite. So, also
wir gucken gleich weiter. Also letztes Jahr, letztes Jahr haben sie es insofern total übertrieben und
zwar die haben noch während Corona quasi gewesen ist, war ja letztes Jahr noch dicke dabei, haben
sie gesagt, hey, wir sind jetzt auch super agile und super modern und ganz, ganz furchtbar krass und
wir machen jetzt eine Homeoffice Vereinbarung. Also sprich, die haben sich da mit dem Betriebsrat
hingesetzt, die haben eine Homeoffice Regelung erstellt und die Homeoffice Regelung lautete,
du kannst das mit einem direkten Vorgesetzten absprechen, wie viele Tage Homeoffice in der Woche
okay sind, beziehungsweise die Anwesenheit für die nächsten paar Wochen planen und das mit einem
Chef ausmachen. Es gibt ein Formular, da kann man auswählen, ob man rein das Homeoffice machen will,
ob man mobiles Arbeiten machen will, wie hoch der Anteil von den jeweiligen Sachen ist. Einzige,
was gesagt wurde ist, bei wichtigen Terminen kann es natürlich auch kurzfristig sein, dass man in die
Firma kommen muss. Klar, wichtige Termine können entweder irgendwelche, was mich nicht, Kick-Off-Veranstaltungen
sein, Projektsachen oder aber auch, es gibt was Neues oder es ist was kaputt gegangen, das ist ja
klar. Und es sollte keiner wirklich einen Monat daheim setzen, das hat man auch dabei gesagt. Aber
ansonsten hieß es im Endeffekt, du kannst das direkt mit deinem Vorgesetzten klären. Also,
was haben wir gemacht? Ich auch, wir haben uns dieses Formular besorgt, haben das ausgefüllt mit
meinem Chef damals zusammen. Ich habe das unterschrieben, mein Chef hat das unterschrieben
und wir haben das eingereicht. So und jetzt dürft ihr mal raten, was für eine Antwort kam beim
einreichen oder nach dem einreichen des Formulars. Zu viel? Ne, ne, ne, noch besser, noch besser,
nicht zu viel, nicht zu viel. Richtig, es kam gar kein, es wurde auch nicht abgelehnt, es kam gar
keine Antwort. Es kam einfach gar keine Antwort. Die haben das einfach komplett ignoriert danach.
So nach dem Motto, die Leute wollen das ja auf einmal machen, was ist denn da los? Das
überrascht uns jetzt aber. Man hat nichts mehr gehört, ich habe bis heute nichts davon gehört,
das Thema wird komplett totgeschwiegen und anstatt darauf mal einzugehen, haben sie gesagt 50%
Anwesenheit. Und jedes Mal, wenn ich mit irgendjemand über dieses Thema gesprochen habe,
hat er mir erzählt, ach wie toll Homeoffice doch funktioniert und wie zufrieden sie sind mit dem,
was ich mache und alles mögliche, aber 50%. Und dann habe ich mir irgendwann gedacht,
wollt ihr mich komplett verarschen? Kann doch nicht sein, dass man sich so offensichtlich nicht an
Abmachungen hält. So und dann war ich ein paar Mal weniger als 50% da und da gab es dann einmal
richtig Anschiss und das war der Moment, wo ich gesagt habe, Leute jetzt könnt ihr mich mal. Ich
habe es jetzt ausprobiert, ob die es wirklich ernst nehmen, aber ja, machen sie. Jetzt habe ich
keinen Bock mehr und Tschüss. Jetzt suche ich mir was anderes und ich habe jetzt ja auch relativ
schnell was anderes gefunden. So sieht es aus. Genau. Ja, das kommt drauf an. Wie gesagt,
also ich bin mir da nicht sicher, ob das wirklich so pauschal stimmt. Deshalb 70k die Luft dünn wird.
Also du brauchst natürlich die passende Region, wo du bist. Wahrscheinlich irgendwo in Dresden
auf Geland wird es wahrscheinlich schwierig. Wobei es die SAP ist da nicht, oder? Keine Ahnung,
wo ist SAP nochmal? Dafür einmal nice, weil du es bist. Weil du es bist, Sekunde.
Ah ja, genau. So und das wollte ich jetzt sagen. Ja, also wenn du da bist, ist natürlich,
wenn du da am Arsch der Welt bist, ist natürlich was anderes. Dafür kostet es auch weniger. Aber
wenn wir sagen, du bist in München oder du bist in Frankfurt oder du bist in Köln, also irgendwo
da, wo ein bisschen Technik ist und wo ein bisschen was los ist und wo große IT-Läden sind, gerade
in der Finanzbranche bezahlt tatsächlich auch wirklich ganz gut. Da geht, wenn man Ahnung hat
und was kann, was die wollen, durchaus auch ganz gut mehr. Die erzählen dir alle, dass nicht mehr
geht, aber da kriegen sie halt keinen. Ist doch egal, wo man ist? Nö, ist überhaupt nicht egal.
Die Region ist extrem entscheidend, was die Gehaltsspanne angeht. Also das ist enorm wichtig.
Es wird vielleicht immer unwichtiger, umso mehr Homeoffice angeboten wird. Das sei mal dahingestellt.
Also du kannst ja theoretisch sagen, wenn ich überhaupt, du kannst ja theoretisch heutzutage
für eine Firma in England oder in Frankreich oder sonst wo arbeiten. Das funktioniert natürlich
auch. Zum Beispiel, das ist genau das, was ich euch gerade noch kurz erzählen wollte. Ein Kollege
von mir, mit dem ich jetzt zusammenarbeite, der dann auch übrigens mit mir zusammen in die neue
Firma wechselt, was eigentlich ganz gut funktioniert hat, er hatte sich ja im Vorfeld auch beworben.
Ich glaube, das habe ich euch schon mal kurz erzählt und er hatte sich beworben auf eine
Stellenanzeige Senior System Engineer oder irgendwie sowas und in der Stellenanzeige,
das war eine der wenigen Stellenanzeigen, wo tatsächlich eine Gehaltsspanne drin stand.
Er hat sich auf eine Stellenanzeige beworben, da stand drin, Senior System Engineer 95 bis 105K.
Hat er sich darauf beworben und die Firma, nee, sorry, es war nicht Senior, es war Senior,
Senior Support Expert oder irgendwie sowas komisches.
Was für den wirklich passt, weil der arbeitet jetzt bei uns ja auch im Operation Center und der
muss viel mit Leuten telefonieren. Also das hätte für den wirklich gut gepasst. Zumindest,
die haben hingeschrieben 95 bis 105K, hat er sich darauf beworben und die haben gesagt,
oh ja, passt ja wunderbar, haben Gespräche gemacht, haben sogar mit ihm Ticketbearbeitung
und Fälle durchgespielt am Telefon und im Teams Call, so wie würden sie das und das bearbeiten.
Was ist ein Senior Support Expert? Gucken wir mal, was man dazu findet oder was Specialist
oder sowas, keine Ahnung. Kann auch Specialist gewesen sein. Gucken wir mal, was ein Senior
Support Specialist macht, keine Ahnung. Thermo Fischer, klingt wie irgendwie so Thermos Kanne
oder so. Ich weiß nicht, Senior Support Specialist, was machen die hier? Ich klick jetzt mal das
erste an, was ich finde. Ihre Aufgaben, sie arbeiten eng mit unseren Kunden in einer 2nd
und 3rd Level Support Funktion, mit deren Anwendungsverstehung. Okay, keine Ahnung,
was auch immer. Zumindest, das ist überhaupt nicht das, was ich erzählen will. Die haben in
der Stellenanzeige, also nicht die, sondern dort, wo er sich beworben hat, die haben in der
Stellenanzeige beschrieben 95 bis 105K und der hat ein komplettes Bewerbungsverfahren durchgemacht
und sie fanden es immer alle ganz toll und gehaltstechnisch waren sie sich auch einig.
Und dann hat er ein Angebot bekommen, abschließend so nach dem Motto, ja, wir machen jetzt alles
fertig und dann kriegen sie das zugeschickt per Mail. Dann hat er ein Angebot bekommen,
ich weiß nicht mal, was es war, ich glaube 74K. Und da hat er dann, hat er sich gedacht,
was? Kegweight? Die haben die ganze Zeit doch von was anderem gesprochen und ihr habt sogar
selbst in der Stellenanzeige geschrieben. Hä, wie kann das sein? Und dann haben die sich rausgeredet
mit, ja, wir haben eine Senior-Stelle ausgeschrieben, aber die Budgetplanung hat uns nur noch Raum
gegeben für eine Nicht-Senior-Stelle. Ich habe auch gedacht, also was seid ihr für ein Kackladen,
wenn sowas passieren kann? Also erstens ist das wahrscheinlich eine Ausrede und zweitens frage
ich mich, also wenn das, wenn das stimmen sollte, fragt man sich, was ist das für eine Planung? Also
wir schreiben Stellen aus, wo sie nicht das Budget für haben. Und das dritte ist was, wenn das alles,
was denken die sich dabei? Also denken die sich jetzt irgendwie, dass jemand sagt, oh, jetzt habe
ich die Firma kennengelernt und jetzt, jetzt bin ich so überzeugt von, jetzt fange ich da auch für
25.000 Euro weniger an oder was? Oder wie? Was denken die sich denn dabei? Ich verstehe es nicht,
keine Ahnung, fast 30.000 Euro weniger an. Nein, die Logik habe ich echt nicht verstanden.
Tja, und dann sieht man, also der Chebat ist wirklich überall. Das war richtige Zeitverschwendung,
hat er auch gesagt, nee, dann nicht. Es ist sehr ernüchternd, habe Abituren bekommen,
keine Zusagen, für was denn? Ah hier, ich habe mich schon um die 40 Bewerbungen abgeschickt und
90% nur Absagen, als was bewirbst du dich denn? Für eine Ausbildung oder für einen Job? Als was
denn? Fachinformatiker Anwendungsentwicklung, also so ist eine Ausbildungsstelle. Ja, eine Sache,
die ich nicht verstehe, die aber leider so ist. Viele schwätzen rum, Hilfe Fachkräftemangel,
aber ausbilden will keiner so richtig. Das ist widersprüchlich, ich verstehe das ehrlich gesagt
auch nicht, wie die sich denken, dass das klappen soll. Ich habe da das beste Beispiel für,
bekannter um drei Ecken, also wirklich um drei Ecken, der Mann von einer Tochter, von einer
Freundin, von meiner Mutter, also wirklich, das ist so, das ist auch nicht mal Verwandtschaft,
wirklich extrem um die Ecke, der macht gerade eine Umschulung, ich glaube auch zum Fachinformatiker
Anwendungsentwicklung und er hat mich gefragt, ob es nicht möglich wäre dort wo ich arbeite,
sein Abschluss, sein Praktikum zu machen, das geht irgendwie eineinhalb Jahre und da muss das
Praktikum machen, dass er irgendwie seine Abschlussprüfung schreiben kann. Also die
kriegen quasi im Endeffekt einen mehr oder weniger fertig ausgelernten, nee quatsch nicht,
ein halbes Jahr oder ein dreiviertel Jahr oder so geht das. Die kriegen mehr oder weniger einen
fix und fertig gelernter Fachinformatiker Anwendungsentwicklung, der übrigens auch,
ich habe den ja ein bisschen ausgefragt was Linux angeht, tatsächlich für den Anwendungsentwickler
mehr Ahnung von Linux hat als von Anwendungsentwicklung, aber das ist ja egal, also den kannst du auf jeden
Fall gebrauchen. Die kriegen quasi, dafür dass sie sich ein dreiviertel Jahr mal drum kümmern und
ihn das da machen lassen, am Ende quasi einen fix und fertig ausgelernten Fachinformatiker,
mit dem sie wirklich was anfangen können, aber sie haben es einfach nicht hinbekommen. Ich habe
zigmal nachgefragt und wie sieht es jetzt aus, wie sieht es jetzt aus, wie sieht es jetzt aus,
aber uns, also da wo ich jetzt arbeite, es hat ja keiner Bock wirklich seinen Job zu machen in
der Richtung und als ich dann gar so hartnäckig war und über meinen Chef noch mal habe anfragen
lassen, hieß es dann noch am gleichen Tag, ach nee das wäre leider nicht möglich, weil keiner
der Fachbereiche Kapazitäten frei hat. Ja klar, das fällt dem natürlich fünf Minuten danach ein,
nachdem mein Chef noch mal gefragt hat. Das ist einfach Ausrede gewesen, vermute ich jetzt mal,
aber bin ich mir relativ sicher, das ist einfach eine Ausrede gewesen, dass man sich nicht drum
kümmern muss und wenn man so schon mit den Azubis umgeht bzw. erst gar nicht anfängt,
dann musst du dich nicht wundern, dass die alle keine Leute mehr finden, wenn keiner ausbildet
und der Planke Hohn kam ja irgendwie zwei, drei Wochen später, da hat unser oberster Vorstands
IT Dude auf irgendeinem Kickoff erzählt, so nach dem Motto, ah sie investieren jetzt richtig in die
Ausbildung, echt, ich bin gerade übers Kabel gerollt, ich glaube ich muss echt mal meine
Verlängerung auswechseln hier. Ja genau, der Planke Hohn kam dann zwei, drei Wochen später,
da hat unser oberer IT Typ erzählt, so nach dem Motto, sie investieren jetzt richtig in
Ausbildung, aber sie haben das Problem, sie finden einfach keine geeigneten Leute. Da denke ich mir
so, alter wollt ihr mich verarschen, ich habe euch quasi auf dem Silbertablett vor zwei Wochen da
einen hingeschickt, ihr hätt einfach nur sagen müssen, ja wir nehmen uns dem jetzt mal ein
Dreiviertel hier an und da hättet ihr einen gehabt, da wird so viel Blödsinn erzählt,
echter Wahnsinn. Ja also jetzt, wie gesagt, Seven Black, das verstehe ich auch nicht so genau,
dass sie alle rumweinen, dass sie keine Leute finden, aber da nicht ausbilden wollen. Es
könnte aber auch sein, ich meine ich kenne jetzt deine Hinterkunde nicht und ich kenne auch deine
Bewerbung nicht, ich meine es könnte natürlich auch sein, dass deine Bewerbung nicht sonderlich
tolle ist. Oder vielleicht hast du irgendwas im Lebenslauf stehen, was nicht so gut ankommt.
Weiß ich ja nicht, ist ja möglich, weil ich mein bei 40 Bewerbungen 90 Prozent noch nicht mal
sich das angucken ist schon relativ hoch, wobei ich das nicht wirklich einschätzen kann, ich
habe schon ewig keine Ausbildung mehr gemacht. Ich steige nächstes Jahr für 65k ein. Das ist
ganz gutes Einstiegsgehalt, da würde ich das auch direkt machen. Bundeswehr, was willst du bei
der Bundeswehr? Okay, also Slackware schreibt übrigens, verwendest du auch Slackware oder
heißt du nur Slackware? Weil dann wärst du der erste, den ich kenne, der wirklich Slackware
verwendet. Also ich verwende indirekt auch Slackware, weil Unraid ist Slackware. Ich benutze
tatsächlich mittlerweile Unraid, ich weiß, ich habe das immer ein bisschen geflamed, aber eigentlich
ist es doch ganz ganz nett für daheim. Er schreibt, ich hatte auch teils Probleme, ich hatte mich
beworben und habe auch viele Absagen bekommen mit Bachelor. Irgendwann findet jedes Huhn mal
ein Qual. Das stimmt wohl. Es könnte natürlich auch ein bisschen an der Region liegen, je nachdem
wie viel es da gibt, schwer zu sagen. Du, das ist ja auch normal, das ist ja auch okay. Deswegen
sage ich ja, es gibt ja prinzipiell drei Wege, wie Unternehmen Leute bekommen können. Entweder
einfach alle mit Geld zuscheißen, sich selbst nach Möglichkeit so attraktiv wie möglich machen,
dass es halt mehr Leute überzeugt oder ihre Ansprüche runter runter schrauben. Letztendlich
wird es wahrscheinlich am Ende eine Kombination aus allem sein, aber wenn ihr bei euch vielleicht
vielleicht nicht absolut hier top high end bezahlen könnt, aber dafür viele anderen Vorteile habt,
was die Leute überzeugen. Ich meine es nicht unbedingt den Obstkorb, der einmal in der Woche
da in der Ecke steht und vielleicht nicht wahnsinnig überzogene Ansprüche habt, dann findet ihr dafür
auch Leute. Wobei man sagen muss 45k, okay für Quereinsteiger oder Leute, die neu anfangen ist
das ja mag das ja noch in Ordnung sein, aber für Leute mit einigen Jahren Berufserfahrung in der
IT, in Bereichen, die gesucht sind beziehungsweise Bereiche, die jetzt nicht jeder machen kann. Ich
meine so ein Windows-Wizard kann jeder durchklicken. Ist das dann doch jetzt nicht unbedingt so der
Wahnsinn. Kannst du nicht was mit Holz machen? Leute, da kann ich mich jedes Mal drüber aufregen.
Also auf was der Chainlord sich hier bezieht, der Chainlord merkt sich die Sachen ja gut,
er ist ja auch schon gefühlt seit 100 Jahren dabei. Das heißt er ist jetzt 105 oder so. Also
der Hintergrund bei dieser Holzsache ist, da kann ich mich jedes mal aufregen, wenn ich
das, wenn ich da dran denke. Ich war, als ich in der 8. Klasse oder so war man das macht keine
Ahnung. Wahrscheinlich in der 8. oder 8. Klasse oder so. Wie alt, okay wie alt ist man in der 8.
Klasse? Also ich bin 1984 geboren. Wie alt ist man in der 8. Klasse? 15 oder so, 14, 14 ja. Also
ich schon ein bisschen her. Zumindest was wir da gemacht haben ist, da war mal so ein Typ vom
Arbeitsamt in der Schule und der hat uns dann erzählt, so wie toll das, wie toll das in
Zukunft alles ist und wie geil das Arbeitsamt ist und wie wichtig das ist was er, was er da macht
und so was. Zumindest daraufhin ist meine Mutter mit mir ins Arbeitsamt gegangen zu dem Typ und wir
haben eine Berufsberatung gemacht oder Berufsorientierung oder wie auch immer das genau hieß. Leute,
das war der größte Scheiß ever. Da hast du solche Fragenbögen gemacht. Da hast du solche
Fragebögen gemacht, so für was du dich interessierst und in welchen Bereichen du gerne arbeiten
würdest und welchen Materialien du gerne arbeitest. Ich habe halt alles ausgefüllt. Ich will was. Okay
Leute, ich konnte euch damals nicht sagen was ich genau machen will. Ich wusste ich wollte was mit
Computer machen. Ich dachte damals ich will eher hardware mäßig was machen, weil ich halt damals
schon gerne einen Computer rumgeschraubt habe und so was. Also habe ich gesagt, okay ich will halt
computer mäßig was machen. Ich hatte damals keine Ahnung. Damals gab es übrigens noch gar
kein fachinformatischer Systemintegration. Den gibt es glaube ich erst seit 2004 oder
2005 oder sowas. Damals gab es noch IT-Systemelektroniker und solche Geschichten. Zumindest habe ich das
ausgefüllt für ich will was IT mäßig Computer mäßiges machen und dann hat er das ausgewertet und hat
gesagt, ja da waren jetzt aber Antworten drin, die die passen nicht zusammen, weil ich habe irgendwie
bei dem einen angekreuzt ich würde gerne handwerklich was machen. Damals habe ich halt an Computer
zusammenbauen gedacht. Damals habe ich mich irgendwie beim was gab es denn damals so für PC
Läden. Keine Ahnung bei irgendeinem PC Schraube laden gesehen, weil ich gerne hardware gebastelt
habe. Aber sehr egal. Also ich habe geschrieben ja handwerklich schon und im anderen habe ich
geschrieben ich würde gerne irgendwie was was am Bildschirm machen. Genau ich habe bei dem einen
geschrieben ich würde gerne ich würde gerne was am Bildschirm machen. Bei dem anderen habe ich
geschrieben ich würde gerne was handwerkliches machen. Dann hat er gesagt das passt aber überhaupt
nicht zusammen. Wie soll er das denn verstehen? Na ja gut ich schraube Computer zusammen und dann
sitze ich am Bildschirm und gucke ob alles funktioniert. So dann hat er gesagt ja ja alles
oder ich weiß nicht wie er das ausgedrückt hat aber wieder echt wie der allerletzte Kackspaß hat
er das ausgedrückt. Ja ja immer alles so mit Computer und so. Also ich hätte ihm am liebsten
irgendwas so ins Gesicht geworfen. Zumindest das Ende vom Lied ist gewesen. Meine Mutter hat
den Kram natürlich geglaubt so nach dem er so das ist ja einer vom Arbeitsamt der hat da voll Plan
von und am Ende ist gewesen dass er mir vorgeschlagen hat ich soll doch was mit Holz lernen. So und im
nachhinein bin ich drauf gekommen. Das war mir damals natürlich nicht klar warum er mir empfohlen
hat ich soll was mit Holz machen. Das ist ganz einfach. Die Typen beim Arbeitsamt die haben
nichts wirklich auch wenn das vordergründig so aussieht. Die haben nicht wirklich die Absicht
was zu finden was für euch passt beziehungsweise was ihr gerne machen wollt oder ihr dem erklärt
was ihr gerne machen wollt und der dann die passenden Berufe raussucht und euch berät. Nein,
nein, nein. Was der vorhat ist offene Stellen besetzen und wenn der 90 Prozent kanadische
Holzfäller braucht dann schlägt er allen vor was mit Holz zu machen. Richtig wichtig genau. Das
geht letztendlich darum dass die irgendwelche ich weiß nicht ob man es auch Quoten in dem Fall
nennen dass das besetzt wird was offen ist. Es geht nicht darum das was für euch zu finden. Das ist
komplett ein Blödsinn deswegen ist diese Beratung komplett für ein Arsch. Das ist für euch kacke
und gerade wenn ihr Eltern habt ihr dann auch noch was drauf geben ist das richtig beschissen. Bei
mir ist es dann darauf rausgelaufen im Endeffekt dass ich tatsächlich habe ich auch schon ein paar
mal erzählt angefangen hat mit der kaufmännischen Ausbildung nachdem ich es ist es ist wieder die
Mario Playlist dass ich tatsächlich mit was kaufmännischem angefangen habe was ich dann
tatsächlich was ich auch nicht weitergemacht habe. Die meinten zu dir auch soll es Bauarbeiter
werden. Ich habe wirklich nichts gegen Bauarbeiter ich bin froh wenn es gescheite Handwerker gibt
wirklich gibt es tatsächlich zu wenig und vor allem welche die man auch zeitlich zeitlich bekommt
also wenn es nach mir geht es dürfen wirklich viel viel mehr Leute ins Handwerk gehen. Das
fände ich persönlich eine super Geschichte und auch auf die Baustelle überhaupt nicht der Punkt
aber es geht nicht bei denen darum was für euch das richtige ist sondern was bei denen gerade am
besten reinpasst. Es ist halt richtig für eine Art und deswegen habe ich damals auch eine Ausbildung
angefangen was kaufmännisches Zeug angeht da habe ich halt überhaupt keinen Bock drauf gehabt
danach habe ich ziviliens gemacht und dann habe ich irgendwann die Ausbildung angefangen zum
Fachinformatiker System Integration das ist ja auch dann endlich das gewesen was ich machen wollte
ja nur dass ich mittlerweile tatsächlich erstaunlich wenig für das wie gerne ich
früher am Rechner rumgeschraubt habe noch mit Hardware zu tun habe
aber gut es ändert sich also die Interessen ja so sieht das so sah es deswegen deswegen schreibt
ihr was von Holz das habe ich schon ein paar mal erzählt und das ist wirklich was wo ich
mich jedes mal darüber aufregen könnte. Moin Leko, dass ich mich jedes mal darüber aufregen
könnte wie sie uns damals verarscht haben. Hallo alle ich war 14 man kann doch nicht ernsthaft
wirklich erwarten dass den 14 jähriger wirklich da stichhaltig was sagen kann. Einer der schon
zehn Jahre arbeitet der kann dir genau sagen was er sich so vorstellt vielleicht aber doch
nicht mit 14. Du kannst mit 14 wenn du es richtig machen würdest, würdest du die Interessen so ein
bisschen abklopfen auch mit ihm vielleicht mal so einen Fragebogen machen und ihm dann erzählen
hey guck mal was gibt es denn da für Möglichkeiten mit 18 auch noch nicht was gibt es denn da für
Möglichkeiten in dieser Richtung vielleicht auch mit dem voraussichtlichen Abschluss was
kann man denn da machen und was sind denn was sind denn mögliche Berufe und dann eben einfach
den Leuten ein bisschen das beraten und erklären was gibt es aber da ging es überhaupt nicht da
drum. Du kannst wirklich nichts davon erwarten. Wie viele Tage Homeoffice willst du haben? Naja so
viel wie möglich so viel wie möglich also ein Tag die Woche ins Büro ist gar kein Problem
finde ich persönlich auch nicht wild. Ich arbeite vier Tage die Woche einer davon ins Büro
also dort wo ich jetzt bin die spinnen ja total so nach dem Motto erst machen wir eine super
Ankündigung und dann sagen wir ach ist mir uns auch alles egal 50 prozent plus Anwesenheit und bei
der neuen Stelle ist es einmal in einmal in der Woche beziehungsweise je nach Absprache mit
dem Chef einmal alle 14 Tage. Kann man nix sagen absolut in Ordnung. McFly lange schon für den Sub. HsYohi auch schon ewig dabei.
Raizu Subscription. Er schreibt ich verstehe nicht warum 2023 Homeoffice immer noch so ein Taputhema ist
es ja nicht ist es nur in manchen Boomer Führungsetagen. Ich verstehe dass es in manchen
Berufen nicht geht das ist ja logisch wenn du Zahnarzt bist ist das mit Homeoffice wahrscheinlich
ein bisschen schwierig oder wenn du Dachdecker bist ist das im Homeoffice auch schwierig und im
Marketing könnte ich mir das vorstellen ist das bestimmt in manchen Fällen auch schwierig also
oder als Krankenschwester es gibt jede Menge Berufe da ist das nicht möglich aber gerade viele
Bürojobs und da geht es ja hauptsächlich drum ist das ohne Probleme möglich. Natürlich muss man gucken
das was zu den Leuten passt ich bin auch nicht der Meinung man sollte die Leute zwingen deswegen
sage ich ja auch nicht man soll eine Homeoffice Pflicht machen wir sind da eh bei ganz vielen
Themen heutzutage viel zu schnell dabei zu sagen man muss es verbieten oder man muss Pflicht machen
oder sonst wie ich bin schon einmal die Leute sollen das frei entscheiden dürfen also man
sollte jetzt keinen der keinen Bock hat daheim zu sein dazu zwingen ins Homeoffice zu gehen es sei
denn er bewirbt sich auf 100 prozent Homeoffice Stelle das ist ja was anderes dann weiß er ja
Bescheid aber das wichtige ist dass du es den Leuten ermöglichst wenn sie das machen wollen
in einem Rahmen wo das halt auch gut passt ich kann es verstehen wenn Unternehmen sagen sie wollen
nicht dass die Leute ein halbes Jahr dass man die halbe als man die halbes Jahr nicht vor Ort sieht
wann Progas eins wollte ich heute Progas machen das kann ich das kann ich ja verstehen Janfried
Dankeschön für den Zap das kann ich ja verstehen aber es ist tatsächlich in vielen Führungsetagen
gerade auch in der Finanzbranche oder so ein bisschen da wo halt jetzt die Führungsriege
vielleicht ein bisschen alteingesessener ist tatsächlich ein Thema wo viele denken wenn sie
die Leute wenn sie die Leute nicht vor Monitor sehen machen die nix das Problem ist aber selbst
wenn sie die Leute vor Monitor sehen wissen sie auch nicht ob die grad was machen oder nicht ich
meine wenn ich den wenn ich den Hacker Typer aufhabe Moment immer stelle euch mal vor unser Chef
unser unser Oberstar ober irgendein Vorstand stellt euch mal vor irgendein Vorstand läuft
durchs Büro und ich sitze so da meint ihr der könnte irgendwie einschätzen was ich da mache
der läuft da durch guckt auf ein Monitor sieht aha der guckt furchtbar der guckt furchtbar
interessiert auf sein Monitor da wird er schon wird er schon irgendwas spannendes machen und
tschüss und das interpretieren die da als auch krass der arbeit der richtig richtig
übrigens es war mal bei uns der Vorstand im Büro das weiß ich noch der hat mal unser unser
unser Obervorstand Chefs Chefstuhl hat mal irgendwelche super VIP Leute rumgeführt bei
uns in der firma und unter anderem wurde dann halt auch das operation center und so was
vorgestellt und zumindest kam sie ins Büro jetzt zumindest kam sie auch ins Büro wo ich
gesessen habe und wie das im Vorfeld natürlich so ist der der Chef von von dort in dem Büro
wo ich sitze der hat an dem Vorfeld schon gesagt ich habe gehört gleich kommt der Vorstand vorbei
leute wir müssen hier mal ein bisschen aufräumen was denn mit aufräumen versteht ist nicht das was
ihr jetzt unter aufräumen versteht also aufräumen für den ist nicht die ist nicht die ist jetzt nicht
wie den schreibt nicht sauber machen also aufräumen bedeutet ist das chat overlay kaputt wirklich
stimmt jetzt einfach kaputt so was sie unter aufräumen verstehen ist folgendes guck mal
ich zeige euch mal so exemplarisch so ein demobil also stellt euch mal vor
ihr habt auf auf einer auf einem auf einem großen bildschirm in der vorne vorne in diesem in diesem
großraumbüro ihr habt dort ein paar große bildschirme wo ganz viele alarme auf sind von
dingern die kaputt sind aufräumen hat der verstanden machen einen zweiten tap auf macht
mal deswegen den screenshot so dass man keine alarme mehr sieht also das war mit aufräumen gemeint also
sprich alle alarme dies tatsächlich gibt verstecken wenn der forst vorbeikommt darf ja keiner sehen dass
es gerade offene alarme gibt also solche dinge solche dinge wurden dann quasi erst mal erst mal
geschlossen und leere tabs aufgemacht und sowas und er meinte auch sitzt mal alle so da dass es
beschäftigt aussieht und wisst ihr was wir dann gemacht haben ohne scheiß wir haben da ich habe
keine vm ich habe keine vm ich kann es euch jetzt gar nicht zeigen ok ja das haben wir aufgemacht
das haben wir aufgemacht auf monitor das ist quasi das ist quasi ein fake so ein fake input
programm das sieht halt übertrieben nach nach hollywood hollywood hacker aus das ding das das
haben wir aufgemacht will ich will ich hatte das offen daneben und übelst übelst rum zeug und ich hatte bei
mir und ich hatte bei mir einfach das ticket das ticket system offen ich hatte bei mir einfach das
ticket system offen und er läuft dann so durch die rein durch und guckt bei meinem kollege auf
den bildschirm und meint oje was denn da los was denn da los guckt zu mir so rüber auf den bildschirm
und ja gut ja das ist das ist ich glaube ich glaube ich glaube hat gesagt ja das ist das ticket
system das kenne ich wenigstens und dann habe ich zu ihm gemeint so ach was ich habe das auch
habe umgeschaltet hat auf dem anderen desktop das auch offen und dann meinte irgendwie so oje oje
was hier los aber ich sehe hier passiert ja einiges habe ich habe ich zu ihm gesagt so in
wirklichkeit ich kann es ihnen jetzt ja verraten in wirklichkeit haben wir das nur aufgemacht weil
wir wussten dass sie vorbeikommen und dann hat er mich angeguckt hat gemeint und ich habe auch zu
ihm gemacht in wirklichkeit in wirklichkeit gehe ich stark davon aus dass er wusste dass das die
wahrheit ist natürlich können das alle seiten nicht so wirklich zugehen ja weil einfach mal
dumm gelacht und gut ist gewesen die sind auch nicht blöd oder die sind auch nicht blöd ich
gehe davon aus der wusste dass das tatsächlich stimmt lachlich das war eher feig lachlich
ich weiß nicht wie ich da von home office drauf gekommen bin aber so sieht es aus ja und leider
ist das tatsächlich gerade was so alteingesessene führungsetagen eigentlich ein problem aber
letztendlich es wird sich klären die nächsten jahre über weil der bedarf an altiv fachkräften
geht da nicht weg der alt der bedarf an altiv fachkräften wird wahrscheinlich eher wenn ich
sogar noch ein bisschen steigen aus ganz einfachen gründen der bedarf an altiv fachpersonal wird
weiter steigen weil es gibt viele jobs die aktuell ersetzt werden durch automatisierung
gehen wir mal von was gut oder sowas wie berger weiter oder so das wird es wahrscheinlich in
zukunft auch nicht mehr in dem umfang geben aber viele jobs die es jetzt gibt werden ersetzt durch
irgendwelche automatisierung automatisierungslösung ganz universell gesprochen belegt euch früher
schon am fließband zehn leute jetzt stehen da vielleicht noch zwei und drei roboterarme dabei
und sonst was und viele bereiche die heute büro jobs machen werden ersetzt durch irgendwelche ich
wenn ich sagen k.i geschichten aber durch irgendwelche automatisierung vielleicht auch
mal in zukunft k.i geschichten so aber die sache ist halt die dort wo zehn stellen wegfallen
so oldschool jobs im endeffekt die fallen ja nicht einfach komplett weg sondern du brauchst ja auch
leute die sich um die neue technik kümmern also ich würde mal sagen ohne dass ich es irgendwie
belegen kann würde ich jetzt einfach mal sagen für zehn jobs die wegfallen brauchst du also
durch automatisierung brauchst du vielleicht zwei neue IT leute die sich eben um solche technik dann
kümmern die gibt es ja jetzt schon nicht und in zukunft wird es wahrscheinlich prozentual
eher noch ein bisschen mehr werden das heißt die finden jetzt schon keine leute mehr die werden
also in zukunft auch keine leute mehr finden und dann kommt halt der punkt die unternehmen
können entweder ihre ansprüche drastisch runterschrauben die leute mit geld zuscheißen
oder sich attraktiver machen und nachdem es im endeffekt eine kombination wahrscheinlich
aus allen drei sein wird läuft darauf raus dass die leute dass die unternehmen die home office
bieten mit einer sinnvollen regelung ich glaube viele sehen es ja durchaus ein dass irgendwie ein
jahr daheim sitzen ohne was von der firma mitzubekommen gar nicht so sinnvoll ist die die das nicht bieten
können und auch nicht die leute mit geld zuscheißen können dass sie quasi alle bedingungen
akzeptieren die so gibt den wird nichts anderes übrig bleiben als entweder sich attraktiver zu
machen unter anderem mit gescheiten home office regelung oder keine leute mehr zu bekommen keine
leute mehr zu bekommen ist wahrscheinlich dann das größere problem als ein paar zugeständnisse
machen obwohl man das nicht will also ich gehe davon aus dass ich das problem erledigen wird über
kurz oder lang und dass die gar nicht drumherum kommen gut ich meine ich werde natürlich weiter
rum heulen so nach dem motto fachkräftemangel und dann kommt dann kommt mit kommen wieder und
sagt fachkräftemangel ganz schlimm und oje was ist denn hier los aber in wirklichkeit liegt es
einfach daran dass keiner bock hat es für das gehalten für die bedingungen zu machen und da
müssen wir halt was dran ändern ansonsten pech gehabt richtig das war richtig wie weit bin
ich eigentlich hinten dran mit dem chat wer will denn als qualifizierte nach deutschland zum
beispiel leute die in den haus in deutschland haben und dort wohne leute die familie und kinder
und eltern in deutschland haben und auch kein bock kam ins ausland ist jetzt nicht wirklich so
dass alle die bisschen planen haben unbedingt weg wollen gibt bestimmt einige gibt bestimmt
auch mehr als deutlich mehr noch als früher gerade jetzt im hinblick auf auf home office
möglichkeiten ist natürlich noch nicht mal gesagt dass du deutschland verlassen
musst um quasi woanders hinzugehen woanders zu arbeiten
schläger eine paketverwaltung tatsächlich keine tage setz mehr
bei phobis computer weil er phobis war der größte kackladen überhaupt übrigens ich
spiele aktuell ganz viel mmo kreisel grind ich habe mittlerweile glaube ich schon 120
spielstunden oder sowas und ich weiß jetzt ein paar griechische beleidigungen nicht nur mal
lacquer malacca kann er kennen jeder ich kann jetzt dadurch dass ich mmo kreisel machen den
ganzen tag ganz viele griechischen beleidigungen weil unser battlegroup leader was pvp angeht ist
grieche und er flamet immer übelst rum ich muss euch demnächst mal wieder ein clip zeigen aber
der ist ausgerastet er tut das muss ich ich suche ich suche gleich mal raus den clip ich
habe mich weg gepisst er ist so am ausflippen was für einen mmo da geht schon kamelot auf
eben das ist ein frees chart 25 jahre alt ist für einen ich glaube sogar 22 jahre alt ist mmo
älter als du siehst du
samuel dankeschön für den sub
jahnfred marks dankeschön für die subs
wie soweit ich gesagt habe man sollte jedem ermöglichen das zu machen was er will ja das
ist richtiger feldschirm pence camp feldschirm ist das wie setzt du da genau auf was bezieht sich das
weiß ich nicht was ist denn fake update punkt net ok ich meine ich klicke ich klicke solche
seiten nicht mehr an ich meine fake update könnte auch sowas wie fake taxi sein oder so
man weiß ja nie wer weiß ich mache die seite auf und als erstes kommt erst mal jepp cock man
kommt das auto das muss ich auch noch machen ja als nächstes mache ich jetzt entweder erst mal
mit dem wenn wir das am wochenende hinkriegen entweder mit dem florian das video über die
hacker hacker hacker man software malware oder ich erzähle was über lebenslauf und sonstige
bewerbungsgeschichten habe ich auch noch gesagt oder ich erzähle euch was irgendwas in der richtung
ja mal gucken ich weiß noch nicht genau aber das auto review dauert wahrscheinlich könnte ich
eigentlich einschieben zwischendurch ist man zu alt für eine physik ausbildung 27 ne ne gar nicht
die frage ist doch eher warum willst du das machen wenn du eigentlich mit computer nix am
hut hast also irgendwas musste ich ja dazu bringen ist es also muss ich jetzt halt fragen ist der einzige
warum du das machen willst weil du kein bock mehr auf deinen alten job hast und denkst it findet man
gut was oder ist das was was dich interessiert weil du musst keine große ahnung haben wenn
du eine ausbildung startest das ist ja auch sinn und zweck der ausbildung dass du danach genug
ahnung hast nicht unbedingt davor ich mein interesse daran und auch ein bisschen so hang
dazu sich selbst damit zu beschäftigen muss schon sein also dass man alles vorgekaut bekommt
beziehungsweise mal wirklich tief tiefgreifende ahnung von dem thema hat nur rein mit dem was
man auf der arbeit lernt ist recht unwahrscheinlich aber was der hintergrund warum das machen willst
aber 27 ist auf jeden fall nicht zu alt 27 ist absolut in ordnung kann man noch mal mit 35 kann
seine ausbildung machen das ist ja auch gut man kann ja als der sinn von der ausbildung ist ja
dass man was lernt deswegen ist es gar nicht so wild weil man keine vorkenntnis hat wichtig ist
dass man sich damit beschäftigen will und in gewissen eigenen antrieb hat was zu lernen weil
wie gesagt rein vorgekaut wird das nix also auch nicht mit der berufsschule oder mit dem mit
ausbildern im betrieb also gewissen hang dazu sich selbst sachen angucken zu müssen auch man schon
können wir noch mal eier natürlich kann man machen ja das geht alles noch also bis
damit mit mit deinem alter ist das überhaupt kein ding hier 27 ist sie es gibt bestimmt
auch noch andere berufe wo man ein bisschen kohle verdienen kann und nicht in der und keine
schicht arbeiten eine schicht aber machen muss wobei es durchaus auch durchaus auch genug jobs in
der it mit schichtarbeit gibt also wenn es sich interessiert du bist auf jeden fall nicht zu alt
also bist auf keinen fall zu alt dafür 27 wein hallo was soll ich sagen ich bin 38 und wirklich
alt würde ich jetzt auch noch nicht sagen also ich bin vielleicht auf dem kalender also im ausweis
der übrigens schon ewig abgelaufen ist muss ich auch muss ich auch noch erneuern bevor ich den
neuen job anfangen ist und jeder geht da nix so ich habe den chat geschafft tatsächlich ich bin
durch wahnsinn hat gedauert ich wollte euch noch was fragen leute und zwar es hat letztens unter den
videos einer gepostet ich muss mal gucken ob ich das kurz finde wartet mal das war
man kann ja youtube kommentare nicht mehr richtig nicht mal richtig durchsuchen glaube es war
eines war einer dieser videos hier man muss ja tatsächlich das ist leute das ist die einzige
möglichkeit youtube kommentare youtube kommentare zu durchsuchen ist eigentlich auch ziemlich
hängen geblieben oder also browser addons gehen auch wie es aber im hintergrund ähnlich machen
richtig richtig hängen geblieben oder was ich hier ist es nicht hier dann weiß ich nicht
wurde wo er das gepostet hat er hat zumindest in dem video gefragt ob ich nicht mal was ich was
ich sehr abstrakt fand er hat gefragt ob ich nicht mal videos zur system integration machen
kann vielleicht auch hier irgendwo keine ahnung da muss ich halt sagen system integration ist so
ein so irgendwie so was sehr nicht sagen dass irgendwie ok man findet keine youtube kommentare
warum findet er hier eigentlich was er findet doch offensichtlich was hier alter mein gott
youtube ist so kacke was das angeht ich bin ich eingeloggt hier nicht lock mich jetzt mit dem
account auch nicht ein hier also da gefragt kannst du nicht videos zum thema system integration
machen das ist wie gesagt super abstrakt ich weiß ich was er genau will aber ich habe mir als ich
das kommand gelesen habe ich mir was überlegt und zwar ich könnte tatsächlich mal zu da muss ich
mal fragen was was ihr was ihr davon was ihr davon halt ich könnte tatsächlich mal zu paar themen
ab und zu die mich persönlich auch interessieren was erzählen das wird dann kein klassisches video
so nach dem motto ich mache einen battlefield gameplay an und schwätze jetzt irgendwie 20
minuten nee ich würde dann wahrscheinlich so was ähnliches machen wie eins zwei beispiele und
so eine art powerpoint präsentation und halt ein paar beispiel in der vm und wir gucken uns das an
also ein bisschen vielleicht vielleicht ein bisschen wie wie das video hier zu dem virus
allerdings würde ich tatsächlich mehr noch power ihr kennt mich wahrscheinlich wird es nicht
powerpoint ja aber wahrscheinlich würde ich ein bisschen powerpoint zeug zeigen zum beispiel zum
beispiel powerpoint schulung so habe ich keine ahnung von die thumbnails die thumbnails mache
ich nicht mehr selbst man sieht das sofort guck mal diese thumbnails habe ich selbst gemacht die
hier macht jetzt jemand für mich das ist sofort besser oder ich meine nicht so beschissen waren
die jetzt auch nicht aber die an die neuen sind schon netter also ich habe mir überlegt ich
könnte zum beispiel mal ein video ich würde gerne erst mal so testweise was machen was alle
so ein bisschen it interessierte auch heimheim server host da anspricht ich würde zum beispiel
mal ganz gerne was zum thema infrastruktur system monitoring machen wo man dann erst mal erzählt
was gibt es für tools warum macht man das welche welche ansätze gibt es das ist ja gar nicht mal
so einfach zu sagen was man für bestimmte anwendungszwecke nehmen soll also das irgendwie
die meisten der sachen auch folgen können muss ich mal gucken ich bastel mal was zusammen
probiere das aus ich gehe nicht davon aus dass es wahnsinnig viele views kriegen wird wahrscheinlich
so 15 20 k was nutze fürs monitor im home lab das ist auch was was ich mit rein nehmen werde
wie das für leute ist die heimbereich was machen weil das ist ja wahrscheinlich das was die meisten
leute eben praktisch praktisch auch benutzen können ich benutze zappings ich benutze zappings
ich habe eine weile ab time kuma gehabt was wirklich cooles projekt ist du wartest auf das
video vom griechen habe ich das wo habe ich das ich habe sie im discord das weiß ich aber im
discord im discord kann ich in discord kann ich gerade nicht weil ich hier im discord nicht
eingeloggt bin den kenne ich vor dem habe ich sogar ein video im hintergrund hier offen was
wir uns nachher vielleicht angucken network mag ich nicht wirklich hier gucke ich nicht gerne
open it cockpit das habe ich mir auch angeguckt schon das fand ich vom ansatz her tatsächlich
ganz cool weil das auch prometor starten und so was integrieren kann das hat aber überhaupt
gar keinen so drive richtig auf github das gibt es eine ganze weile und 166 sterne für eine open
source monitoring lösung erscheint mir jetzt irgendwie ist das das video ja das ist das video
auf fack ich habe den chat zugemacht nur das ist das video wobei kann ich das aufmachen also
ich habe ein problem ich habe ein problem der typ der bei uns der bei uns pvp anführer gibt
ja der flucht immer auf griechisch rum und ich habe keine ahnung was der sagt also da könnte
durchaus irgendwas in richtung ich fick deine mutter oder oder noch schlimmeres sagen ich habe
keine ahnung und ich zeige ungern sachen wo ich nicht weiß was die leute sagen egal ich
mache das jetzt ich mache das jetzt mal auf also ihr müsst ja gut sind sound aus ich mache das
jetzt auf ok also vielleicht kann jemand griechisch von euch leute das ist die
chance die chance habe ich nie kann jemand griechisch von euch kann jemand ein bisschen
mein schimpfwörter schimpfwörter können die meisten wahrscheinlich kann jemand griechisch
von euch weil ich würde echt gerne wissen was der typ sagt griechisch ja mal
lacquer mehr kann ich nicht ich kann um malacca als griechische schimpfwort ok also was ihr
wissen müsst das ist ein video aus dem pvp und wo habe ich den sound jetzt ich blick nicht mehr
durch ok was auch immer das ist ein video aus dem pvp und wir machen nicht das beziehungsweise
manche leute machen nicht das was wir machen sollen ok oder rastet er rastet gleich mega aus
passt mal auf also wir sind im discord und wir spielen halt hier pvp so pass mal auf er rastet
übelst aus videos plus neun sekunden lang und schlägt irgendwas vom tisch
ich könnte mich da jedes mal wegschweißen bei dem typ alda das geht jeden abend ab und
zu mal so es passiert fast jeden abend irgendwas wo die leute nicht das am ende was ich ausgemacht
habe ist griechisch also ich habe mal nachgeguckt es heißt glaube ich irgendwie sowas wie ich fickt
deine mutter und es passiert fast jeden abend irgendwas wo die leute nicht das machen was sie
machen sollen und dann rastet er komplett aus er ist ohne scheiß der typ ist der einzige grund
warum ich auf dem server dort spiele wo ich spiele ich finde das ist wahnsinnig unterhaltsam klingt
jetzt vielleicht erst mal nicht so das ist wahnsinnig unterhaltsam unter macht das auch gut also ich
habe selten gesehen dass das dass das pvp in dem game so geordnet läuft normalerweise ist das
äußerst äußerst chaotisch aber der scheißt halt die leute auch permanent und macht die leute auch
permanent zur sau lassen sie sich dann auch dran halten aber er ist der einzige grund warum ich
auf diesem server spiele und ich lasse mich gerne von ihm an kacken das griechische habe
ich wie gesagt das griechische habe ich ausgemacht weil ich keine ahnung habe was er genau sagt
ja verbal verbal an kacken aber ich kann mir schon vorstellen dass manche im chat natürlich
gleich wieder an miss das habe ich gar nicht als im out dass die mal das viele im chat wieder an
pepo toilet zoom gedacht haben
was wegen dem typ werden videospiele moment was videospiele werden für die silvester
krawalle verantwortlich gemacht das habe ich jetzt nicht mitbekommen echt jetzt ich habe das
keine ahnung habe ich nicht mitgekriegt was haben denn silvester krawalle jetzt mit videospielen
wieder zu tun ok das ist jetzt was neues den zusammenhang verstehe ich aber gar nicht
ach bei der tante beim presseclub ja gut presseclub da war wahrscheinlich eine so vom verschnitt
regine pfeiffer oder so da und hat sonstige sachen erzählt als haben die als haben die
silvester krawalle was mit mit mit mit spielen zu tun man muss ich muss mal so ein blick auf
das klientel werfen bei den silvester krawallen da ist vollkommen vollkommen normal ist auf der
straße mit schreckschusspistolen rum zu rennen rum zu ballern also dass das irgendwie mit
videospielen zu tun hat wird mich doch ganz stark wundern genau das ist cs go zers russia das hat
alle trainiert für silvester wieder 32 32 wie das war der einzige modus den man spielen konnte
außer 16 verses 16 rush 16 verses 16 verses 16 rush ist auch ok ich habe jetzt so lange
geschwätzt komme ich bin jetzt eine stunde 17 on wie habe ich bauchweh weiß ich ob ich zu
viel gefuttert habe heute abend video über die IT Trends von Morpheus schon gesehen nee habe ich
nicht wie heißt er irgendwie so IT Trends programmier sprachen frameworks und mehr Trends
2023 schon chat gpt angeschaut im stream nee wir haben doch indirekt wir haben im stream wir
haben wir haben chat gpt im stream mal gefragt was man gegen backseating im chat machen kann und
die antwort war sehr chat gpt style also viel äußerst sachlich und und es gibt mehrere
möglichkeiten eine der möglichkeiten ist es bla bla bla bla chat gpt hört sich ja immer so hat
so einen gewissen aufbau dass man hört das irgendwie also zumindest kann man sachen lesen
und sich denken dabei das könnte auch so von chat gpt sein ich habe mir jetzt letztens erst
einen account gemacht hat eine weile gedauert dass man sich wieder registrieren kann ich habe
mir gedacht ich frage chat gpt mal was aus meinem letzten video was dieser code macht da bin ich
mal nämlich gespannt ob chat gpt weiß was das hier macht diese decoding routine mit goto und label
da würde ich mir echt da die in die wird mich mal interessieren ob die mir das ordentlich erklären
kann und er sieht ob mir das chat gpt ordentlich erklären kann klaro dankeschön für den sub also
leute meint ihr dieses video programmier sprachen frameworks und mehr trends 2023 können wir uns
angucken dass das doch mal durch df wollte ich wollte ich die einzige pass mal auf all
moment falsche mache ich was mich ein bisschen abgeschreckt hat ist
es ist nicht so dass diese tools täglich verwende ja was mich ein bisschen abgeschreckt hat ist
diese warning und zwar dass es manchmal vorkommen kann dass das ins speicher geladen wird und
ausgeführt wird und man soll besonders vorsichtig sein wenn man vermutet dass es sich um malware
handelt nicht das aus versehen was ausgeführt wird das hat mich ein bisschen stutzig gemacht
dass ich vielleicht nicht einfach komplett planlos sachen in dem die opferskater öffnen sollte wahrscheinlich
ist es gar nicht so schlimm wie es da steht aber man weiß ja nie also das war eine warnung die
hat mich erst mal ein bisschen abgeschreckt ok wisst ihr wie sehr mich das aufregt dieses dass
man nicht mehr weil eine task leiste ist komplett useless da ist nix nix aber ich muss hier über
so dämliche zwischenmenüs gehen ok also das video meint ihr was ok gucken wir uns mal an
technologie trends icon sind die mitte ist ja noch schlimmer dann kann man mit
winderskaste richtig mit maus zeigen in die unten linke ecke schieben programmier sprachen
und technologien von dominiert die programmier sprachen was kann man sich jetzt darüber streiten
eher javascript aber pice ist auf jeden fall oben mit dabei von dominiert die programmier sprachen
javascript wird am meisten genutzt und sie wird wieder beliebter jeder nutz geht und reakt so
lange es nicht c++ ist habe ich damit auch keine probleme ist vollkommen ok aber c++ nicht und
nein frag mich bitte nicht warum c++ sonst arte das heute wieder aus das ist bin aus elf ja ich
kann nichts anderes verwenden als wenn aus elf das ist neu das ist mein neuer rechner 13.900 k und
wenn aus elf ist natürlich neben linux ja das einzige betriebssystem was in den ordentlichen
multithreading task scheduler hat der die architektur ordentlich unterstützt mit efficiency course und
performance course und alle möglichen
nicht ok also technologie trends 2023 gucken wir uns mal ist das beliebt das video ein bisschen
dunkel oder ist mein desktop einfach so dunkel framework aber warum ist das eigentlich so und
was solltet ihr am besten lernen im so der programmier sprachen 2023
und und warum ist chrome zu blöd meine leiste ordentlich auszublenden
du kannst ja in den taskleisten optionen das gruppieren der schallflächen deaktivieren
das geht nicht mehr das gibt seit winners elf nicht mehr kuck du kannst das nicht mehr
ausschalten das ging unter winters zehn aber unter winters elf gibt es das nicht mehr weil
sich microsoft gedacht hat wer möchte schon seine taskleiste ungruppiert haben
und da haben die sich gedacht so ein legacy feature bauen wir nicht mehr ein wird zeit dass
die taskleiste mal mit rust neu programmiert wird play singly fast und written in rust und
überhaupt beste beste taskleiste ever taskbar es genau mit so einer komischen
grabe dahinter im eiken als eiken taskbar es und dann so eine grabe dahinter
es gibt zwei große queren die uns entwicklern einen guten überblick geben mit was unsere
kollegen so arbeiten die ist der twitch chat und den teo beindex beide sind natürlich ja gut
oder github trends ist teilweise auch ganz perfekt aber es geht um eine richtung was euch demnächst
erwarten könnte dieses video hier habe ich übrigens auch schon die letzten beiden jahre
gemacht dieses jahr wird es deswegen ein bisschen anders wir wollen darüber reden warum dinge so
sind wie sie sind und für wen jeweils was relevant ist ihr dürft dann selber entscheiden wo ihr euch
einordnet ich werde auch den vergleich zu den letzten jahren ziehen oder zu vor allem den letzten
jahr das ist aber trotzdem nur das erste von fünf solcher videos in den nächsten wochen erwarten zu
verschiedenen themen und passend zum thema sehen wir eines dass zumindest meine entwicklung in der
jüngsten zeit komplett dominiert hat chat gpt die ki zu der ich schon ein video gemacht habe doch
ich war zwischen weihnachten neuer nicht untätig sondern an einer entwicklung mit einigen tausend
seinen code beteiligt alles davon mit chat gpt und meine erfahrung möchte ich mit euch teilen bei
der job iow von get in it das ist wer das ist javascript hat wie auch letztes jahr bei stack
overflow den ersten platz belegt das heißt was am meisten genutzt wird und zwar mit ein paar leute
warum hat das video oben und unten schwarze balken liegt es am seiten am format von ihm oder ist das
irgendwas was chrome gerade verkackt
lernen im so der prognose das ist das sei das ist das sein videos format wahrscheinlich 16 zu
10 monitor oder sowas ordentlichen abstand die erste andere sprache die dann wirklich noch genutzt
wurde ist python von über 20 prozent weniger leuten im professionellen umfeld professionellen
umfeld stehen sie halt irgendwie aus mir nicht näher erklärbaren gründen stehen sie halt auf
java meinetwegen ist es allerdings die zweit beliebteste sprache html zählt nicht spannend
ist aber speziell hier der vergleich zum vorjahr javascript wird im vergleich von weniger
professionellen entwicklern genutzt während python gestiegen ist die erklärung warum javascript so
beliebt ist aber trotzdem sehr einfach javascript ist die einzige sprache die wirklich für
websiteentwicklung im frontend genutzt wird alle frameworks im web development frontend jetzt
kommen wahrscheinlich wieder leute ja aber web assembly aber praktisch gesehen kommst du
trotzdem auch mit web assembly nicht ohne javascript aus du kannst ja in web assembly
noch nicht mal den button auf einer seite machen oder das click event mitbekommen richtig also
brauchst javascript da kommst du nicht drumherum wir hatten mit javascript eigentlich benutzt und
außerdem ist auch javascript mit elektron auf dem desktop wichtig weil irgendwie muss man
32 gigabyte auf java seitiger code für web apps wird häufig mit javascript geschrieben
note js führt tatsächlich sogar die liste der web frameworks kurz vor reakt an das heißt von
allen javascript entwicklern arbeiten etwa die hälfte auch im backend mit javascript und sogar
dort läuft javascript in mehr als der hälfte der fälle in kombination mit dem express framework
das zu arbeiten mit das sind sache damit kann ich mich überhaupt nicht anfreunden note js
meinetwegen express ist wirklich nicht mein react hingegen ist das beliebteste frontend framework
natürlich auch in javascript das aber immer noch besser als 10 plus plus allerdings mit
deutlichem abstand und ein wenig später kommt view js spannend ist aber auch dass gerade
unter den professionellen entwicklern asp.net core die 20 prozent markt mittlerweile geknackt
hat und damit ist das seht ihr mal wie professionell wir hier im stream sind wir machen zu 90 prozent
asp.net core backends systema professional streamer konfront zum vorher überholt hat hinter der
javascript und jetzt soll mal jetzt soll mal irgendeiner sagen wir machen hier nur blödsinn
im stream oder es hat keine das sieht man mal wie wie praxis relevant das alles ist da kann man
könnte man schon mal fast schon auf der arbeit wenn man den stream guckt das ganze als fortbildung
einreichen oder zumindest die arbeitszeit buchen im bettbereich mit seinen frameworks flask und
django da aber python und c-sharp im frontend eigentlich nicht zu finden sind kann man jetzt
ziemlich gut sagen ja blazer ist ja auch kacke weiss ich was microsoft sich mit blazer gedacht
hat ja also ich fand blazer von anfang ok als ich als alle als das aller allererste mal von blazer
gehört habe dachte ich mir cool c-sharp im frontend nachdem ich dann blazer benutzt habe
dachte ich mir wer braucht diesen mist und nachdem ich jetzt die letzten jahre über das ganze so
ein bisschen verfolge ich habe keine ahnung was warum und weshalb ich jemals blazer verwenden
sollte bei the way verfolgst du die ruby entwicklung ein bisschen ja
ein bisschen ich habe mitgekriegt dass die die letzte version jetzt ziemlich große performance
prünge drin hatten ja aber nicht wieso was gab es denn zu ruby
was hältst du von typeskripp hat das relevante ja es hat viele typeskripp hat hinter java script
oder fast schon gleich auf mittlerweile mit java script recht viel relevanz gerade bei größeren
projekten auch im business umfeld typeskripp sehr beliebt performansprung bei ruby habe ich
gesehen ja jquery da sieht man mal es gibt technologien die sind zwar überhaupt nicht
mehr angesagt aber die verschwinden einfach nicht beispielsweise sowas wie komot aber bei
bei jquery sieht man es halt es ist übrigens noch gar nicht so lange her dass jquery hier
wirklich an oberster stelle war mit meist benutzt man muss sich mal vorstellen ich glaube wenn es
so ein übergreifenden übergreifende analyse gibt verwenden glaube ich immer noch an die 50
prozent der weltweiten webseiten wie jquery oder sowas das ist echt der wahnsinn also jquery ist
zwar überhaupt nicht mehr angesagt aber total viele seiten verwenden noch jquery 21 bleiben
wird sowohl im frontend als auch zu einem großen teil im backend ja da wird sich nicht so viel
an wenn man nach full stack entwicklern sucht ihnen nur eine programmiersprache zu geben und
dafür einfach zwei frameworks nämlich react zum beispiel im frontend note und express im backend
werden die teams aufgeteilt also man hat leute die nur frontend machen und leute die nur backend
und leute die cobalt machen dann hat man eher die wahl übrigens typescript als add-on für
javascript hat sich unter allen programmiersprachen insgesamt den rang nummer 5 erarbeitet wobei
davor auch sql und html css dabei waren also von den reinen sprachen ist es sogar auf platz 3
spannend dabei ich finde das gar nicht so schlimm ich mein hey streng genommen kann man jetzt bestimmt
argumentieren und sagen ne ja was html css das sind keine programmiersprachen das mag ganz
streng formal durchaus richtig sein wobei ich mir selbst da bei manchen konstrukten gerade in css
was irgendwie rekursive aufrufe und so angeht gar nicht mehr so sicher wäre ob das wirklich rein
formal nicht vielleicht doch mittlerweile als programmiersprache durchgeht aber ich bin da
nicht so pingelig also auch wenn mir in den azubi erzählt so nach dem motto ich kann ich
ich kann html programmieren ich finde es immer ein bisschen cringe wenn man den leuten dann
erzählt ha du kannst nicht html programmieren html ist keine programmiersprache html ist nur
markt ab oder also ich weiß nicht es ist doch absolut sollen sie es doch sagen ja das hatte
heute also rudy schreibt
heute hatte ich einen sehr schönen moment auf der arbeit ein kollege der gegenüber von mir
hockt hatte heute ein kundenswerk fernwartung angerufen dann reden sie ein bisschen und der
kunde wollte den kohle merchen dann sagte was passiert wenn ich hier drücke und andere verweckt
ja ist ein bisschen blöd live die sachen auszuprobieren was die knöpfe auf dem
telefon machen übrigens bei uns gibt es jetzt gar keine telefone mehr geht jetzt alles nur
noch über teams die haben es jetzt irgendwie nach zwei jahren geschafft dass wir endlich
über teams gescheit telefonieren können ich kann word programmieren wenn du vba programmieren
kannst es ist eine ganz legitime programmiersprache aber nicht auf word beschränkt doch gucken wir
mal weiter um frage ob javascript geliebt oder gehasst wird sagt nur 62 prozent dass
sie javascript wirklich mögen naja mich würde mal interessieren wo c++ ich würde mir echt
interessieren wo c++ abgeschnitten ist in dieser wahrscheinlich irgendwo irgendwo
ich weiß gar nicht ob das überhaupt da drinnen steht
ich glaube c++ muss der muss komplett umgedreht sein 15 prozent mögen es es gibt immer leute
die auch ganz abartige sachen mögen also 15 prozent mögen sie wahrscheinlich mögen 85 prozent nicht
naja rest kann ich nachvollziehen rust ist irgendwie so ein bisschen so eine glaubenssache
ist im technischen umfeld zwar nicht so aber rust triggert die leute also wenn irgendjemand
eine software veröffentlicht dann dauert es und das gewisse also wenn es software gibt die
ein bisschen beliebt hat dann dauert meistens nicht lang bis es ein rust rewrite von irgendjemanden
oder rust clone von irgendwas gibt das wird dann auf stackoverflow gepostet auf stackoverflow kommt
dann blazingly fast written in rust und warum das so viel geiler ist in rust und die vorteile von
rust kommen bei ganz vielen sachen da gar nicht so sehr zur geltung also rust hat ja neben der
performance noch einen anderen vorteil also der vorteil von rust ist ja dass du performance mit
weitgehendem memory hinter weitgehend sichere memory handling verbinden kannst also du kannst
die sachen sicherlich noch ein quänchen schneller vielleicht machen in c aber da hast du halt andere
probleme wurde dir ins bein schießen oder schießen kannst rust ist die einzige sprache die schafft
wirklich mega performance plus zum größten teil nicht anfällig für die gängigen sicherheitslücken
zu sein ohne dass es eine menschsprache ist mit überall boundary checks und jit und haste nicht
gesehen es hat schon seine vorteile aber viele tools die in rust programmiert werden brauchen
das gar nicht weder die performance noch noch diese dieses es muss alles super verifizierbar
sein was dann irgendwelche was dann irgendwelche tools die färben dein terminal farbig auch das
wirklich die wirklich großen vorteile von rust weil die nachteile weil die nachteile von rust
die sehe ich vielleicht als jemand vielleicht bin ich jemand der einfach nur nicht genug rust
programmiert hat ich habe mich mit rust mal ein paar wochen lang wirklich intensiv beschäftigt
als es ganz neu war und jetzt immer mal wieder so ein bisschen also ich bin kein kein wie nennt
sich crust rastassian crust wie auch immer also ich bin jetzt kein kein rust verfechter
unbedingt und ich finde schon dass rust nicht sonderlich gut lesbar ist also rast hat eine
ultra komplexität rast ist auch vom flow her überhaupt nicht schön zu lesen die zeilen sind
sind sind sind sehr lang oftmals und auch mit ganz viel renundantem zeug fragezeichen unwrap
unwrap option unwrap unwrap option also also ich weiß nicht ob die der programmier komfort in
rust das jetzt irgendwie also die performance bei den tools den verminderten programmier komfort
irgendwie aufwiegt rastassian ja aber anscheinend ist rust und man sieht hier dran irgendwie dass
rast ganz weit vorne irgendwie ist rast ein bisschen zu einer kleinen klaubsache geworden
also das sieht man auch bei den hacker news bei den hacker news post was der overflow posts bei
github issues erinnert sich vielleicht noch irgendjemand an diese rast web library oder
entwickler gesagt hat pickt euch ich stelle die entwicklung ein weil jetzt kommt es weil sie
ihnen issues genervt haben er würde rast nicht genug rast like verwenden kein spaß das war
ein super erfolgreiches web back end projekt in rust eines der ersten und die haben den entwickler
auf github so sehr genervt mit issues dass er eben rast nicht rast like genug verwendet dass
er irgendwann keinen bock mehr geworfen hat und und dass das handtuch geschmissen hat er hat
unsafe in seinem code gehabt und er hat vielleicht ab und zu auch mal irgendwelche funktionen
importiert was auch immer das war zu wenig zu wenig rast like und das hat die angepissten
deswegen haben sie ihn zugespammt auf github und dann hat er irgendwann gesagt ich hab keinen bock
mehr das projekt zu maintain gibt es neue issues im fiat champ ja es gibt genug offene worum ich
mich endlich mal kümmern müsste nicht wirklich issues das meiste sind eigentlich eher feature
requests es gibt ein neues issue im fiat champ nämlich dass er probleme hat sein jeep zu
connecten ich vermute jeep schickt an der stelle hier ein string als stattzenden rein also als
stattzenden nummer ja die rast taskforce ist schon immer aktiv auf hackernews sobald irgendwas ist
kommt einer um die ecke aber das könnte man auch in rust machen ich verstehe schon also rast ist
was ist halt so eine sprache die auch von der technologie so ein bisschen die leute polarisiert
ja cooler ansatz und für viele so quasi dass das das neue theme man macht nichts mehr in
zehe alles nur noch in rust und aber halt auch ein bisschen eigenwillige syntax dass man erst
so nach einer gewissen einarbeitungszeit wirklich flüssig rast schreiben kann und die leute die
sich dann eingearbeitet haben schwören drauf und sagen es die beste syntax aller zeiten die
geilste sprache aller zeiten und also rast ist wirklich so ein ding jetzt ist ein super super
sprache und der ansatz her ist nahezu einzigartig also was mozilla sich da ausgedacht hat ist
wirklich cool aber so ein bisschen bisschen klaubskrieg springt bei rust immer mit bei
typescript waren es 72 julia kann ich nichts zu sagen habe ich noch nie was gemacht soll julia
nicht pyson ablösen das ist genauso wie soll rast c ablösen es ist selten der fall dass
irgendwelche sprachen überhaupt was ablösen ich mein irgendjemand hat sich auch mal überlegt c
plus plus soll quasi c ablösen das war so die bescheuertste idee aller zeiten weil c mal ganz
im ernst c ist nervig zu programmieren aber nicht nicht weil es irgendwie so komplex ist oder weil
c an sich kompliziert wäre sondern weil einfach die standard library und die konstrukte halt
bisschen in die jahre gekommen sind in c hat ja gar keine richtige standard library eigentlich
du hast so ein paar header die jedes jede plattform implementiert zur absoluten basic so wie lang ist
ein string und so was und wie mache ich eine konsolenausgabe aber das meiste in c ist ja
nur wirklich sehr sehr barebone und du brauchst halt für jeden furz in c irgendwelche zusatz
libraries gibt selbstverständlich auch keinen ordentlichen package manager weil c ist aus
zeiten auch kein package manager gedacht es gibt so ein paar third party geschichten die aber auch
kein so wirklich interessieren und das nervige an c ist einfach dass es halt wenig eingebaute
funktionen verfügt es ist anders nervig als c plus plus c plus plus hat schlicht und zu viel
und zu wir also c ist eine super sprache an sich für sich genommen allerdings ist halt die
funktionalität und gerade wenn du also sachen braucht wie den dictionary oder so was zum
beispiel ja oder oder eine liste wo du was anhängst und kein bock hast jetzt wirklich jedes mal von
hand manuelles memory management zu machen ist halt mit c geht da nicht so viel du kannst dann
irgendwelche libraries einbinden und jonglier ist dann irgendwelche header files alles schön
und gut kann man machen ist aber nicht so schön deswegen finde ich c aus der perspektive nervig
und c plus plus ist das genaue gegenteil c plus plus ist mittlerweile zu geflastert mit features
die noch nicht mal das kremium selbst versteht und einheitlich es implementiert man nach diesem
schema man nach diesem schema manche sachen legacy der predicate manches so es gibt für manche
manche dinger fünf verschiedene möglichkeiten wie man es schreiben kann manches darf man nicht
mehr verwenden weil es sagt so macht man das in modern c++ nicht dann hast du ganz viele
eckigen klammern in eckigen klammern und fragt sich was macht diese zeile eigentlich ach so ja
holt mir eigentlich plus millisekunden aus der aktuellen urzeit raus sind c plus plus aber
drei zeilen mit 25 geschachtelten klammern mittlerweile und dann haben sie trotzdem die
elementarsten sachen in ihrer standard library nicht c++ hat beispielsweise immer noch und ich
verstehe ja sogar warum es leuchtet mir sogar ein warum c++ hat beispielsweise immer noch keinen
ordentlichen http klein in der standard library ja ich verstehe warum weil es halt nicht klar ist
ob auf der jeweiligen plattform wo das ganze läuft das überhaupt sinnvoll ist aber das sollte
ein noch nicht davon abhalten so was zu spezifizieren man kann es doch machen dass es halt unabhängig
also dass es quasi abhängig von der plattform ist was denn genau unterstützt wird also das machen
sie ja bei dotnet auch es gibt ja funktionen die werden beispielsweise nur unter windows unterstützen
oder linux oder beispielsweise auf mobile nicht dann kriegst du halt eine exception in dotnet ich
glaube es ist eine plattform uns plattform unsupportet exception oder sowas das heißt
dass kannst du nicht verwenden das meiste gilt aber gut wenn ich jetzt halt auf jeden micro controller
bin ohne tcp überhaupt netzwerk wirklich keine da brauche ich keine ttp klein aber warum wird
das nicht wenigstens mal spezifizieren ich denke das sind so einfache sachen die könnten sie im
c++ cremium wirklich mal machen richtig richtig dann hast du so sagt hast du Probleme mit wie
machst du https wie machst du ssl und solche geschichten das wäre halt wirklich gerade in c++
da ist gott und die welt mittlerweile in der standard library auf fünf verschiedene varianten
kannst du da sachen machen du kannst aber dafür die einfachsten sachen teilweise nicht richtig
machen wusste dass sie in c++ lange zeit ich glaube mittlerweile ist es in der standard library
drinne konntest du mit dem standard string nicht to lowercase und to uppercase machen das gab es
einfach nicht da haben sie c++ entwickler gedacht wer zum teufel möchte denn groß und kleinschreibung
von einer zeichenkette ändern legacy feature das braucht man nicht heutzutage wird das alles so
gelassen wie es ist ja der unicode support ist rotten schlecht in einer c++ standard library also
das sind alles so dinge wo ich könnte da könnte man durchaus mal anpacken ich brauche nicht die
fünfte smart pointer variante oder die die 75e variante wie wie ich irgendwelche air type left
type double air type und hast du nicht gesehen parameter mache wo eh keine saume durchblickt
in c++ sondern einfach mal was wirklich sinnvolles einbauen und nach möglichkeit vielleicht
irgendwie die sache ein bisschen einheitlicher machen du hast fünf varianten wie du funktionen schreiben
kannst mittlerweile also oder klassenmethoden in c++ kannst du in return type schreiben mit
einem feil du kannst einfach return auto machen kannst du es ist einfach unglaublich wir das
ganze nur es ist einfach total durcheinander ja c++ talk da wollten wir eigentlich gar nicht
hin stimmt schon da wollte ich gar nicht hin aber es ist wirklich wir also diese sprache kann man
verstehen dass sie hier nicht auftaucht die machen sie auch die letzten jahre über nur noch schlimmer
macht type script die dritt beliebteste sprache bei stack overflow witzigerweise sieht es bei
den web frameworks komplett anders aus beliebt sind vor allem phoenix von elixier ok phoenix
habe ich noch nie verwendet swelt ist poc swelt benutze ich auch gerne das welt ist nice für
javascript asp.net core und deno richtig unbeliebt deno ok das deno so beliebt ist hätte ich gar
nicht mal gedacht das überrascht mich jetzt ein bisschen
ey ich zeige euch mal Leute passt mal auf das muss jetzt sein mal ein beispieler für
warum c++ so scheiße ist mir fällt das gerade ein ich habe nämlich gerade das
beides beispiele gefunden also passt mal auf anwälte also was ich machen will in c++ das
ist das letzte das ich euch damit nerfe aber das muss jetzt einfach sein ich möchte aus einer
liste einen bestimmten wert löschen also ich möchte sowas machen wie remove if also ich
habe eine liste mit zahlen drinne und ich möchte die liste filtern quasi nach sagen wir mal ich
möchte alle alle fünfen ich möchte alle fünfen aus der liste rauswerfen also in einer ordentlichen
programmiersparetsin deine liste da würdest du dann vielleicht sowas machen wie entweder
direkt auf der liste implement remove if oder du würdest sowas machen wie map oder du willst
sowas machen wie selle selle wer select was auch immer ja würdest du würdest du also in c
scharp würdest du es so machen zum beispiel das wer number und dann sagst du hier größer 5 und da
hier was weiß ich da kommt jetzt eine neue liste raus die nur noch nummern enthält die größer
oder noch zahlen die größer 5 sind also 6 7 8 9 was immer easy so wisst ihr wie das ganze in c++
aussieht ich habe hier nur ein beispiel für einen wert löschen aus dem c++ vector keckt mal ne runde
so sieht das in c++ aus
ich mein was zum vector erase ok soweit gehe ich noch mit soweit gehe ich noch mit
also für sowas einfaches was schlimmeres das ist ja abartig jetzt schon das ist das ist das ist
das ist alles was in c++ kacke ist in einer zeile
so da musst du so komische dinger hier machen standard remove vector begin vector end value
vn es auch abartig das sound auch abgehackt sollte nicht sein
remove if jetzt weiß ich wie ich auf remove if komme remove if war c++ genau jetzt weiß ich
stimmt stimmt richtig richtig ja das geht jetzt wenn du was ganz neues hast geht das wahrscheinlich
wirklich so wenn du was ganz neues hast geht das wahrscheinlich wirklich so das ist tatsächlich
schon besser wobei ich halt sagen muss es ist auch nicht schön weil warum muss ich standard remove
if machen und kann ich sagen vector also warum hat bitteschön vector erase nicht einfach die
möglichkeit dort den lambda zu übergeben und es funktioniert also warum warum geht nicht einfach
sowas zum beispiel so was oder warum warum nicht wenigstens irgendwie filter oder irgendwie so
etwas wäre ja wäre ja auch schon mal was da könnte man das wenigstens lesen das ist natürlich besser
warum ich jetzt unbedingt vector begin vector end hinschreiben muss es halt so eine 10 plus plus
eigenheit und an die lambda syntax kann man sich kann man sich zur not auch noch gewöhnen
was man aber hieran sieht was auch schon wieder was richtig nerviges an c++ ist
erstmal auf c++ remove if wird erst unterstützt seit c++ 17 und dann implementieren noch nicht
mal alle compiler c++ 17 richtig also es kann durchaus sein dass du ein compiler hast er zwar
c++ 17 implementiert aber das nicht und ich benutze c++ hauptsächlich für esp 32 und esp 32 hatte
lange zeit irgendeine uralt gcc version die kaum was davon implementiert hatte den compiler stellst
du in der idee ein ich kann in meiner idee so viel einstellen wie ich will wenn es für meine
plattform nichts gibt was das unterstützt da kann ich viel einstellen in meiner idee
remove if ist generisch nicht speziell für weg ich weiß ich weiß mir ist klar warum die das so
machen aber es ist jetzt ja nicht so als könnte man da nicht was dran ändern dass man solche
sachen eben auch auf einem vector verwenden könnte also in dort net haben sie es zum beispiel so
gemacht das finde ich im nachhinein eigentlich wirklich clever ich habe mir da ich habe mir da
früher nie was bei gedacht aber also wie gesagt ihr wisst ja ich habe meine meine programmier
sachen damals angefangen 2000 2002 habe ich damals mit dort net angefangen mit c sharp damals
angefangen ein bisschen später pyson was war das 23 oder sowas rumgespielt und aber erst seitdem
ich immer mehr programmiersprachen gelernt habe ist mir aufgefallen wie clever die das eigentlich
damals in dort net gemacht haben und zwar die haben es geschafft retroaktiv ihren list listen
elementen also quasi so was wie ein vector in c++ auszustatten mit zusätzlichen funktionen
ohne die rückwärts kompatibilität kaputt zu machen und haben sie das gemacht sie haben
eine möglichkeit geschaffen dass du quasi klassen überladen kannst mit metoden ohne dass du die
klasse selbst ändern musst das nennt sich in dort in c sharp nennt sich das extension method und
das ist was wirklich cleveres weil da kannst du einfach ein liste auf int kannst du erweitern
ohne dass du selbst quasi zugriff auf die internen sachen der listen klasse haben musst dass du
kannst damit relativ easy standard library funktionen erweitern das ist ja ein ding
der unmöglichkeit in c++ wenn du sagst ach fuck der standard string hat die und die methode nicht
in c++ die ich brauche dann überschreibe ich das mal und erweitere das selbst das kannst du nicht
weil c++ standard string ist standard library da ist mit erweiterung nichts ich kann es abklasse
davon machen und das ableiten und dann frisst wieder kaum ein anderes framework und sowas kann
ich machen aber extension messen zwar eine wirklich super clevere geschichte ist mir jetzt erst im
nachhinein aufgefallen einige jahre später super clevere geschichte von den dotnet entwicklern
damals noch von anders hailsberg und mittlerweile ist es ja ob ich auch in den norweger oder
ausgewandene norweger ist ja glaube ich jetzt ist die scharpe entwicklung chef ja so so haben
wir das gemacht das finde ich eine super geschichte weil ganz ehrlich standard remove if mag ja
ganz nice sein deutlich cooler ist das wenn man das direkt auf dem objekt aufrufen kann egal
genug c++ rand wir gucken das video weiter man kann den c++ noch nicht mal davon ableiten
ok das das wusste ich nicht wobei doch oder du kannst kannst du nicht das abklasse nee du hast
recht du kannst keine subklasse machen von standard string was du machen kannst ist noch
mehr eklige c++ sachen du kannst constructor overload gedöns verwenden das geht auch irgendwie
du kannst auch quasi sagen assignment assignment overload oder sowas in der richtung dass du
quasi so tun kannst als ob du abgeleitet hättest von standard string aber in wirklichkeit ist es
ein eigener typ wo du einfach quasi den assignment operator überschreibst dass es so aussieht als
wäre es ja ja ganz abartiges zeug also das sind so dinge wo ich mich halt frage könnten
sie nicht da einfach mal eins zwei c++ revision wirklich aufräumen und das alles einheitlicher
machen und vielleicht mal die dinger so unglaublich wir sind ein bisschen griffiger machen man könnte
aus c++ durchaus eine sinnvolle sprache machen die man auch gerne benutzt aber nicht so was das
kremium da macht so jetzt reicht es aber dagegen angela js angela monka ist im wettbereich auch
nicht ganz genau so hätte es auch eingeschätzt leute angela dagegen angela js moment angela
js sorry moment war immer ist angela js das neue oder das alte
angela js ist das alte ach so ja gut dass das so unbeliebt ist verstehe ich das
ja das normale angela hat auch schon keine allzu gute anzugröpft das flask so unbeliebt
ist verstehe ich gar nicht für so ganz mini anwendung ist das doch ganz nice das asp dort
net so weit unten ist verstehe ich wohlgemerkt leute microsoft benahmung schlägt wieder zu wir
reden von asp dort netz und nicht von asp dort net core ich hoffe euch ist allen der
unterschied klar zwischen asp dort net und asp dort net core und gar zwischen asp dort net core 5 und
asp dort net 6 weil wenn ihr denkt dass asp dort net core eine mini dass asp dort net core 5 eine
quasi minimal version von asp dort net ist also das seid ihr komplett seid ihr liegt ihr komplett
falsch microsoft ist nämlich der meinung seine produkte so unglaublich 5 hätte benennen zu
müssen dass keiner mehr durchblickt jetzt ist mittlerweile alles dort net das hat aber die
verwirrung noch kompletter gemacht also nur mal so zur erklärung also ganz gerne asp dort net core
5 ist neuer deutlich neuer und auch keine minimal version von asp von asp dort net 6 also asp dort
net core 5 ist deutlich neuer als asp dort net 6 asp dort net 6 ist die ganz ganz alte asp dort
die letzte asp dort net version auf dem normalen dort net framework basierte dort net framework war
das was windows only war bis version 4.8 ging das ganze das letzte dort net framework war dort net
framework 4.8 so und die kunde passende passende passende musikuntermalung dazu
zehn stunden perfekt passende musikuntermalung dazu
um die um die verwirrung um die verwirrung jetzt auch komplett zu machen also es gibt
schon ganz lange seit 2002 gibt es das dort net framework und das dort net framework wir können
uns auch mal kurz wir gucken uns einfach ein bild dazu an warum ist es jetzt zugegangen
hier dort net history jetzt wird es natürlich viel klarer wenn ich dieses bild aufmache hoffe
ich mal ganz ganz logisch jetzt ist jetzt ist jetzt ist alles geht es nur bis 2017 das für
den schwachsinn 2017 er viel besser alter max ist nicht in der lage im internet zu browsing
was windows timeline an hier unten ok also nur um die sache jetzt was ein riesen diagramm
nur diesen scheiß zu erklären man versteht hoffentlich also wir machen das jetzt mal im
schnelldurchgang irgendwann kam dort net framework raus so dort net framework gibt es bis version
4.8 hier bis version 4.8 die hier gar nicht drinne steht hier doch 4.8 so irgendwann hat
microsoft festgestellt dort net framework sagt so viel legacy sachen drinne schwierig zu erweitern
dumme idee deswegen kamen sie so ungefähr zu zeiten von dort net framework 4.6 auf die idee
diese ganze dort net geschichte noch mal neu zu entwickeln und diesmal cross platform rausgekommen
ist dort net core also dort net core ist keine weiterentwicklung vom dort net framework ist noch
nicht mal verwandt mit dem dort net framework microsoft hat sich bloß gedacht wir benennen
das so dass es sich anhört wie eine minimal version von diesem framework zur komplette
neuentwicklung dort net core gab es dann bis dort net core version 3 beziehungsweise 3.1 dort
net framework wurde eingestellt mit 4.8 dort net core 3.1 wurde dann zum release quasi von dort
net core 4 umbenannt in dort net 5 und jetzt heißen die sachen bloß noch dort net seit version 5 was
eigentlich intern eine weiterentwicklung von dort net core 3.1 ist also quasi dort net core 4 wurde
umbenannt dort net 5 das problem ist jetzt nur dass dort net 5 sich anhört wie eine
weiterentwicklung von dort net framework 4.8 weil was liegt näher wenn jemand keine ahnung hat zu
vermuten dass dort net 5 was mit 4.8 zu tun hat oder mit 3.1 also ich glaube die meisten
leute denken mit 4.8 stimmt aber nicht es ist eine weiterentwicklung von dort net core 3.1 so
und seit version 5 gibt es gibt es nur noch dort net und alles heißt dort net das blöde ist
jetzt nur um mal zurückzukommen auf asp dort net asp dort net war das web framework dort net
framework das gab es zwischenseitig lief das auch aber das war das web framework für das
dort net framework und sie haben im zuge dort net core asp dort net core auch neu entwickelt und
asp dort net core hatte immer die gleiche versionsnummer wie das framework also hier
version 2 hier version 3 und jetzt version 6 das dumme ist jetzt nur das dumme ist jetzt nur dass
es hier irgendwann mal 2010 oder so gab es asp dort net 6 und jetzt gibt es asp dort net core 6
was nichts miteinander zu tun hat und die leute blicken das nicht was ja verständlich ist man am
besten ist ohne scheiß am besten ist man hört einfach auf an dieser stelle man vergisst alles
was davor gewesen ist man vergisst dass es dort net framework gab oder irgendwas gegeben hat sondern
redet einfach nur noch von dort net und ich nur hier ja mono falls einer mono gehört hat mono
war ein nachbau vom dort net framework der allerdings auch unter lehnungs gelaufen ist ok ich lasse
euch jetzt aber damit in ruhe was man sieht microsoft hat sich schon wirklich was beigedacht
zurück zum video leider sieht die bezahlung im webbereich auch nicht ganz so rosig aus javascript
ist mit einem jährlichen durchschnittsgehalt von 65.000 dollar in den aus dem weg geringe gering
verdiener javascript da und richtig gut bezahlt wird hingegen phoenix und ruby on rails ruby
vielleicht ist das der grund warum phoenix und elixir so beliebt sind auf platz 2 hat sich aber
wie auch im jahr davor pfeifen und was ist jetzt mit dort net standard ok leute ihr dürft euch jetzt
ausruhen soll ich noch kurz sagen was dort net standard ist oder wollt ihr eure ruhe haben von
microsoft versions benahmung die sollten es dort net version 10 denn ja das wäre wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich schlecht also dort net standard dort net standard das ist tatsächlich in dem fall in
dem fall relativ einfach dort net standard beschreibt eine spezifikation das ist keine
keine runtime oder so dort net standard ist eine spezifikation das heißt wenn du eine dort net
kompatible runtime programmierst und du sagst ich möchte dort net standard 2.0 unterstützen
heißt das im endeffekt nur dass deine standard library einen gewissen satz an funktionen und
klassen bieten muss dass sie eben kompatibel zu dort net standard zum beispiel in dort net
standard steht drin es muss eine daytime klasse geben es muss eine console rightline geben es
muss einen es muss eine liste geben und so was steht da drin also dort net standard definiert
welche apis das anbieten muss um eben diesen standard zu erfüllen erfüllen genau das heißt
wenn du jetzt verschiedene dort net implementierung hast du hast ja mono du hast dort net core du hast
das dort net framework gibt es ja gibt es ja alles weiterhin ja du hast dort net micro framework
du hast vielleicht noch andere entwicklung also wenn du möchtest dass deine programme auf jedem auf
jeder runtime laufen die mindestens dort net standard 2.0 beispielsweise implementiert dann
darfst du nur sachen verwenden die dort net standard 2.0 quasi vorgibt als muss implementiert
sein praktisch gesehen ist das im büstesumfeld vielleicht relevant ansonsten ziemlich irrelevant
weil so gut wie jeder verwendet schlicht und ergreifend einfach die neuste dort net core sorry
dort net version also intern dort net core war das mal wer das auf thema dort net ja auf geht's
berichte mal morgen wie es gelaufen es interessiert mich fast der hälfte der stimmen zählt mittlerweile
definitiv auch python zu den must haves gerade unter den lernenden genieß python eine unfassbare
beliebtheit die sprache ist einfach zu lernen und ziemlich flexibel man kann sie fast überall
anwenden man findet python im wettbereich etwas aber vielmehr ist python ein allrounder deswegen
gab es auch im teobe index den platz eins für python schafft man unter den beliebtesten anderen
also nicht den web frameworks findet man direkt unter dem dort net framework numpy und pandas
dort net ist ziemlich weit oben ich finde das ist verdient ihr wisst ich bin kein großer windows
fan und auch kein wirklich groß microsoft fan gibt vieles was mich daran stört aber dort net
ist eine gute sache visual studio code ist eine coole sache und sie schab entwickelt sich auch
gut es gibt einige berechtigte kritik an das die schabentwicklung der letzten jahre dass da
vieles doppeldeutige eingebaut wurde beziehungsweise machen auf die gleiche art und weise oder manchmal
hat microsoft sachen eingebaut weil sie die selbst brauchen und sonst keiner auf der welt
ja aber im großen und ganzen ist dort net sehr nice was man auch hier jetzt mittags sieht und
ich finde sie schaap ist für mich immer noch die beste allround programmier sprache kannst die
schaap und dort net koffe nahezu alles verwenden außer außer für microcontroller gibt zwar das
micro das das nano framework aber das glaube ich verwendet keiner so wirklich aber ansonsten kannst
du alles mitmachen desktop anwendung weg ins theoretisch theoretisch kannst du damit auf
webseiten machen aber blazer finde ich kacke kannst theoretisch damit auch mobile anwendung
machen aber maui mag ich auch nicht ich mag nicht alles aus dort net ökosystem aber für die für
für kommando zeilen tools für backends web backends ist dort net ist das was ich standardmäßig
nehme es sei denn es gibt jetzt irgendein fall dass ich sage ok für dieses projekt wäre was
anderes besser zum beispiel als ich mal eine weile was gebastelt habe webrtc habe ich das
tatsächlich in go gemacht weil die mit abstand beste webrtc library gibt es in go also wenn
man jetzt nicht im browser mit javascript unterwegs auf dem server server seitlich
du kannst auch auf raspberry pipe gut sachen in dort net machen da bietet sich wiederum
halt vielleicht pyson an wenn man sagt man möchte irgendwelche sensoren auslesen und
spannung messen oder oder temperatur messen sowas da bietet sich pyson vielleicht dann auch eher an
weil dafür gibt es halt für jeden feldwald und wiesen sensor irgendwelche libraries für c-sharp
findet man bei den meisten sensoren auch libraries aber da wird schon ein bisschen knapp weil
c-sharp hat halt keine irgendwie große historie was embedded sachen angeht und auch keine große
historie was so sachen wie raspberry pie angeht wird besser wird besser aber da hat pyson halt seine
stärke weil auch viele hardware hersteller als erstes in der pyson library mitliegt also
wo wir eigentlich wieder beim punkt sind das meiste hat seine daseinsberechtigung außer
vielleicht ja doch leider leider hat c++ auch seine daseinsberechtigung hobel auch leider
ist leider ist es bei c++ so gerade wer unreal verwenden will kommt wahrscheinlich wenn er
irgendwelche logik sachen dort erweitern will interne sachen nicht wirklich um c++ rum und
wer microcontroller programmieren will kommt eigentlich auch nicht um c++ rum oder halt um c
aber bei aduino ist es in c++ dialect und esp 32 ist es das standard framework zwar alles in c
aber die angenehmeren sachen sie arbeiten gerade an der eigenen scriptsprache für unreal es
gibt ja für unreal mittlerweile schon verschiedene addons die ich gesehen habe also es gibt wohl einen
dotnet plug in ich weiß nicht add in oder wie nennt man das bei unreal dass du dass du die
meisten sachen in sie scharf machen kannst aber ich gehe davon aus wenn du wirklich sachen in die
engine einbauen also wenn du nicht nur das benutzen willst was da ist sondern wenn du wirklich selbst
sachen in die engine einbauen willst sagen wir jetzt zum beispiel ok ich habe keine ahnung von
unreal ich denke mir jetzt mal was aus vielleicht vielleicht ist es auch komplett falsch ja sagen
wir mal ich programmieren unreal spiel und ich möchte jetzt irgendwie so eine ganz spezielle
licht reflektion haben die halt unreal standardmäßig nicht kann und ich ist mir auch nicht hilft dass
ich irgendwelche wobei licht reflektion ist wahrscheinlich die grafikan shader oder so aber
bleiben wir mal bei dem beispiel also ich will irgendwas was die engine auch mit allen möglichen
settings nicht so macht wie ich das wie ich haben will oder sagen wir mal ich will vielleicht dass
ich die physik engine ein bisschen anders verhält in manchen fällen als das was ich mit settings
tunen kann dann werde ich wahrscheinlich nicht an c++ vorbeikommen weil die einzelheiten und die
details und die internen sachen sind halt nun mal in c++ vermute ich mal gut chat chat gibt mir
recht und wir wissen ja auch der chat hat prinzipiell immer recht also das ist halt das was ich
vermutet vermutet hätte ja das ist glaube ich in unity gar nicht so viel anders unity ist ja im
im kern auch c++ nur dass die halt schon lange mono ist es immer noch gell dass die schon lange
mono dabei haben als als runtime für die für das meiste für die logik und halt dementsprechend
sich ab unity gibt den ich den source code kann sich aber es gibt auch sau viele rennen der
addons und sowas für unity also da muss auch schon irgendwas irgendwas möglich sein zumindest ich
habe keine ahnung von game engines das ist so einfach was ich mir zu zusammen gereimt habe
da kommst halt auch nicht dran vorbei und microcontroller technisch kommst du da
halt an sie uns die also vor allem wenn es ado ino ist oder sp 32 mit platformer auch nicht an
c++ vorbei leider aber ansonsten würde ich einen ganz großen bogen um c++ machen das sind wohl
die beiden wichtigsten bibliotheken für data science und machine learning da dort net meiner
meinung nach schon fast eine umgebung ist und der platz vier spring ein eigentlich ein web
framework ist für java holt sich python also quasi die ersten drei blätze denn nach spring
landet tensor flow direkt auf dem nächsten platz tensor flow ist das framework schlechthin für
neuronale netze und künstliche intelligenz und ist auch meistens in python benutzt nach flache
einem framework wenn du mal einen stressigen job mit weniger bezahlung suchst sollst du dich
einmal intensiv mit game engines auseinandersetzen ich setze mich immer dann mit sachen auseinander
wenn ich persönlich irgendwas habe was mich interessiert und dann lerne ich das auch meistens
quasi von anfang bis bis ende ist es nie aber von also ok ich muss das ich muss das anders sagen
wenn ich mich wenn mich was nicht interessiert lerne ich es in der regel auch nicht dann gucke
ich mir gar nicht an juckt mich dann auch überhaupt nicht sobald mich was interessiert vor allem
meistens weil ich irgendwas machen will wo sich das halt anbietet oder wo man das vielleicht so
gerne oder drin machen kann dann lerne ich das innerhalb von zwei monaten von null auf
fortgeschritten ich mache dann wirklich zwei monate kaum was anderes ihr seht das teilweise
in streams es gibt dinger da höre ich dann gar nicht mit auf nach zwei monaten ist dann oftmals
schon die luft raus dann habe ich schon wieder kein bock mehr drauf aber wenn mich was interessiert
da bin ich äußerst hartnäckig was so was angeht also sollte ich irgendwann mal mich mich so wie
hätte meine oma jetzt gesagt wenn mir mal der furz quer sitzt und ich der meinung bin ich will
jetzt unbedingt in den game machen oder irgendwas wozu eine game engine sinnvoll wäre es wird
wahrscheinlich kein game sein also wenn ich irgendwann mal der meinung bin das will ich
jetzt unbedingt machen dann beschäftige ich mich wahrscheinlich auch damit unabhängig davon ob
ich damit irgendwann mal geld verdiene oder nicht ja das hat meine oma immer gesagt die meinte das
zu so oder was war was kann es sonst auch dazu sagen so wenn ich die mücke sticht oder so was also
wenn es dir jetzt halt grad mal danach ist sozusagen wenn du jetzt wenn du jetzt auf einmal der
meinung bist das musst jetzt machen so hat meine oma immer dazu gesagt wenn ihr der furz quer sitzt
eigentlich total bescheuerte rede wendung ich glaube man versteht ja was er sagen wollte
das da fangen wir jetzt nicht auch noch mit an
ich glaube da habe ich sogar eine erklärung zu als als als kommando im chat machen wir ausrufe
zeichen eins ich glaube dazu gibt es gibt es eine erklärung gar nicht null gar nicht überhaupt
nicht ohne mist weder unreal noch unity haben ich jemals in den fingern gekribbelt das einzige was
ich tatsächlich mal lange zeit wirklich gesuchtet habe und viel drinne gemacht habe ist der half
life 1 level editor worldcraft hieß das damals heute heißt glaube ich hammer worldcraft ich
habe damals half life 1 maps gebaut multiplayer maps auch ich habe mich auch damals ein paar
cs maps versucht aber da war ich zu schlecht für da habe ich das habe ich tatsächlich monate und
ganz ganz ganz ganz lange gemacht also wäre jahre lang also ich würde wahrscheinlich heute im half
life 1 level editor noch eine map zusammenbekommen die zwar kacke aussieht nach heute nach heutigen
maß stehen aber f1 ganz ok da habe ich viel mitgemacht das war aber das einzige was ich
jemals in puncto spielerentwicklung gemacht habe was er noch nicht mal spielerentwicklung nennen
kann so richtig aber aus diesem segment so weiter kommt dann auch wieder was von pfeifen nämlich
sidekit lernen und kurz darauf kaffka und pytorch alles framework kaffka ist aber doch nicht in
pyson oder die häufig mit python genutzt werden spannend ist hier aber der kaffka hat es mit
allem kaffka ist so eine art message queue und denen die gerade koden lernen oder ein hobby
cute endlich mal leute was für uns dabei oder die noobs die das qt aussprechen flatter achso das
ist was die leute lernen wollen ok die leute wollen lernen nam pai pandas ok kann ich verstehen
dort netten so flotter und cute überlegt gerade was würde mich davon interessieren dort nicht
kann ich schon heißen und maschine learning ist bis jetzt juckt mich da noch nicht so richtig in
den fingern für cute habe ich ein bisschen plan von keras weiß ich gar nicht was es ist spring
ist ja war habe ich gar keinen bock elektron kenne ich mich genug aus dass ich damit nichts
machen will gtk mann wer macht denn freiwillig gtk sammarin wird ja immer ekliger ionic tatsächlich
tatsächlich wäre von der ganzen sache noch ionic das was mich am meisten interessieren würde
allein schon aus dem grund weil ich dann wenigstens in der lage wäre ordentliche mobile anwendung zu
erstellen wenn ich das mal machen möchte das einzige mobile technische was ich bisher gemacht
habe ist halt eine pwa gewesen was du dir quasi startbildschirm eine webseite für startbildschirm
quasi flatter auf flatter habe ich tatsächlich kein bock weil flatter ist da das mag alles schön
sein schön und gut aber schock mich jetzt nicht so ionic würde mich tatsächlich interessieren
was zum teufel sind hugging face transformers
nämlich ein bisschen an alien professionell wird weniger numpy eingesetzt aber wenn numpy dann
eigentlich auch immer mit pandas kafka hingegen wird kaum gelernt nur 2 prozent im professionellen
ist das recht beliebt aber deutlich häufiger treten als das bestätigt auch ein wenig meine
beobachtung python wird überdurchschnittlich häufig für private projekte zum lernen oder für
dinge genutzt die einfach spaß machen klar professionell ist es auch viel im einsatz vor
allem im data science bereich aber insgesamt arbeiten glaube ich einfach weniger menschen als
data scientists als beispielsweise als web developer besonders interessant ist aber auch hier der
vergleich der guten jahr während die data science und machine learning frameworks wie numpy pandas
oder tensorflow im professionellen zum glück haben sie dort nett jetzt zusammengefasst zurückgegangen
sind ist kafka von gar nicht vorhanden auf fast 12 prozent gestiegen insgesamt ist python aber
vielleicht war letztes jahr nicht in umfrage drin 67 prozent der stimmen die sagen dass python
eigentlich toll ist allerdings ist auch python was die bezahlung angeht eher in der unteren
hälfte angesiedelt spark und immer noch immer noch mehr als javascript die beiden frameworks die
am besten bezahlt werden es kommt also bei python wohl extrem darauf an in welchem bereich man
eigentlich okay wir müssen unbedingt mit kafka beschäftigen sehe ich sehe ich schon wenn man
sich allerdings in die nähe der hardware begibt wird python und javascript schnell nicht mehr
ausreichen stattdessen blicken wir auf 20 prozent 17 prozent ich habe es ja gerade gesagt du kommst
leider nicht dran vorbei aber seriously die tun mir alle leid und sogar 4,5 prozent die mit assembly
arbeiten müssen dazu muss man kurz sagen dass hier auch entwickler für beispielsweise python
bibliotheken mit reinfallen denn python kann z-bindings das heißt wenn ihr eine python bibliothek
schreibt könnte das auch in c plus die meisten reddit posts so oder oder oder hacker news blog
post so nach dem motto it's placing the fast in python das sind meistens irgendwelche leute
die haben was in c oder c plus plus programmiert haben python bindings drauf gemacht und rufen
das aus dem python script jetzt auf oder aus dem python programm auf und sagen hoho guck mal her
wie schnell das ist ne das einzige was schnelles ist dass der zb dass der was in c programmiert
es eben aufruft und auch wenn die drei eher im unteren bereich der beliebtheit angesiedelt sind
haben sie plus plus hat ernsthaft 50 50 warum hat dieser schrott 50 50 mann wer läuft bitteschön
c plus plus c plus plus müsste 15 85 oder sowas haben du will ja verstehen
ok das pearl nicht gut ist warum hat c bitteschön doch eine gewisse fanbase und einen ziemlich
einzigartigen anwendungsbereich hardware bau teile programmieren firmware schreiben und das
wahnsinnig effizient denn auf so einen kleinen teil auf so einem chip passt einfach nicht so
viel drauf jetzt hat sich hier ja nicht wirklich was verändert zum vorher warum also die erwähnung
ich vermute persönlich dass in den nächsten jahren und natürlich dementsprechend auch 2023
der bedarf an hardware nahe entwicklung nach oben gehen wird und zwar steil smart home und
iot wird immer mehr und vielleicht gibt es das ja auch bald ein bisschen auf diesem kanal hier
während allerdings der bedarf an neuen apps zumindest bei mir als konsument auf einem all
time lowest ich habe gar kein bock mehr was neues zu installieren ist gerade einer der
spannendsten standards für iot rausgekommen matter die rede ist natürlich von matter und das muss
aber noch implementiert werden solange die durchschnittliche bezahlung nur ganz knapp über
der von python liegt müsste mir persönlich allerdings jemand einen ganz besonderen anreiz
geben mir assembly wirklich anzutun aber genau das ist im letzten jahr eigentlich auch schon
passiert 2021 war das durchschnittliche jahresgehalt für assembly 20.000 dollar tiefer als heute das
sind über 25 prozent steigerung fairerweise muss man dazu sagen die gehälter sind überall
deutlich gestiegen im durchschnitt sind das etwa 23 prozent gewesen dennoch steigt assembly
schneller als andere was mir signalisiert dass interessant hätte ich gar nicht gedacht dort
besonders viele entwickler gebraucht werden wo wir aber gerade bei der bezahlung sind die höchste
bezahlung hat der bank vor der finanzbranche leute nicht cobol was schon in ein paar nachrichten
kein cobol oder wurde gefragt wie jetzt irgendwie cobol lernen soll für bessere bezahlung kein
geld und das will man wirklich nicht stattdessen doch doch doch chat wir haben im stream schon
cobol gemacht und ihr fandet cobol alle ganz toll aber wahrscheinlich fandet ihr cobol
plus toll weil ihr es nicht machen musstet und ich das gemacht habe dicht gefolgt von erlang auf
dem ersten da sind alles sprachen für leute die auf klammern stehen erlang und closure man macht
macht dieses macht dieses fisch macht dieses fisch fisch ascii ding ich weiß gar nicht mal wie
das richtig geht irgendwie mal diesen fisch ascii fisch machen und das ist bestimmt gültiges erlang
mit einem durchschnittlichen gehalt von 16.000 dollar ist noch immer wirklich wirklich gut
bezahlt zum vergleich mit python oder typescript seid ihr mehr als 30 prozent schlechter bezahlt
phoenix als web framework hatten wir ja schon falls ihr elixir entwickler seid am besten arbeitet ihr
dann noch mit chef als devops und chef ernsthaft
das benutzt noch irgendjemand ich finde chef cool muss ich sagen aber ich hatte nie den eindruck
dass chef die wahnsinnsverbreitung bekommen hat ok das ist wahrscheinlich die paar leute die das im
großen stil verwenden die werden halt auch gut bezahlt polumi leute wir haben das richtige
gelernt letztens also die tools die tools sind aber sehr merkwürdig guck mal chef polumi terra
vom puppet homebrew das ist ein package manager kuba nades jan npm das sind doch komplett ok
es sind alles tools aber so komplett aus unter also was ganz was anderes alles müsste anscheinend
können mehr leute ansobel als chef also chef chef ist cool chef ist eine ist quasi so was wie
ansobel nur dass du es direkt in ruby programmierst eigentlich finde ich chef cool aber ich hätte also
meinem persönlichen empfinden nach das muss ja nicht der wahrheit entsprechen aber hat sich chef
nie so großartig durchgesetzt und puppet ist auf dem absteigenden ast also puppet war lange
zeit oder platzhirsch was automatisierung angeht oder infrastructure as service bevor es das wort
gibt oder nicht infrastructure infrastructure as code nicht infrastructure service infrastructure
as code also iak quasi iak aber in letzten jahren hauptsächlich ansobel und das verstehe
ich auch ansobel wir haben viel puppet code noch auf der arbeit aber mir persönlich geht ansobel
deutlich angenehmer von der hand als abend chef habe ich ehrlich gesagt nie viel gemacht ich finde
die idee cool dass quasi automatisierungstools mit vollständiger programmiersprache dahinter
so was macht polumi besser als terraform gar nichts sind unterschiedliche sind unterschiedliche
ansätze terraform ist eher so reines beschreib mal was du haben willst und polumi hat halt die
möglichkeit dass du deine beschreib mal was du haben willst eben in einer vollständigen
programmiersprache erstellen kannst also in terraform schreibt sie zum beispiel ein eine
datei das steht drin ich will fünf kisten bei asia fünf vms bei asia angelegt haben mit einem
linux drauf und diesen ip und dazu bitte den load balancer davor das schreibst du dann in
deine datei rein und gut ist wenn du jetzt bei das war es dann aber auch ja das ist also terraform
ist da recht recht statisch du kannst reinschreiben was du brauchst und gut ist mit polumi hast du die
möglichkeit das gleiche quasi wie in terraform das das gleiche wie in terraform am ende raus
kommt aber du kannst den polumi beispielsweise javascript oder c-sharp oder sonst was verwenden
um diese definitionen anzulegen das heißt könnt es zum beispiel ein web-request machen und anhand
dieser response entscheiden lege ich jetzt drei oder fünf server an was weiß ich du hast ich muss
mir jetzt ein bisschen die beispiel aus den fingern saugen was das ist möglichst überschaubar bleibt
gelte vor du hast ein monitoring system leute ich weiß dass man skalierung anders macht aber ich
bringe das beispiel jetzt trotzdem was ein monitoring system wurde die auslastung von
deinem die netzwerkauslastung oder nicht jetzt die die die user auslastung user pro user requests
überwachs so und jetzt möchtest du jetzt möchtest du weil du über 10.000 user bist schnell noch mal
zwei zusätzliche server installieren automatisiert das für den fall der fälle dass es jetzt vielleicht
15.000 user werden dein service weiter funktioniert da kannst du in polumi quasi den web-request machen
beim beim lauf und dann anhand der response entscheiden aha ich baue jetzt fünf server auf
dann liest er den state ein stellt fest wir haben plus drei und zählt das hoch auf fünf das kann
man machen das ist mit terraform so in der art und weise nicht möglich weil du eben nicht
vollständige programmiersprache drum herum hast neben deiner definition ansonsten wenn du so was
skalieren willst würde ich normalerweise nicht unbedingt über den web-request in meinem provisioning
tool machen sondern nach möglichkeit irgendwie anderweitig automatisch entweder hast du gleich
sind das alles container und du kannst relativ easy skalieren unter der haube schon so dass du
gar nicht irgendwie neu dein config management zeug anwärmen anwerfen muss also was dann entweder
kubernetes laufen oder sowas in der richtung ja oder du benutzt beispielsweise skalierungsmechanism
von cloud anbieter die bieten das ja auch mittlerweile alle an dass du automatisch quasi
schon im vorfeld neue notes starten kannst selbst wenn nur predicted wird dass jetzt mehr last
kommt also google hat beispielsweise was ganz cooles google hat einen globalen hatte tp load
balancer der wahrscheinlich mittlerweile über maschine learning erraten kann oder oder vorher
sagen kann wann deine ressourcen zu knapp werden also zum beispiel du hast einmal im monat den
riesen besucher ansturm weil dort irgendwelche abrechnungen bereit gestellt werden und dann
hast du einmal im monat riesen ansturm und dann hast du vielleicht drei tage später noch einen
weiteren ansturm weil die leute die da im dort im urlaub waren dann anfang des jahres wiederkommt
und die haben mittlerweile eine logik dahinter dass der eine weile dein traffic und dein user
verhalten analysiert und dann schon wenn der weiß hey gleich kommen statistisch gesehen mehr
anfragen als sonst startet das ding schon weitere application surfer im hintergrund für dich da
muss halt ein server template anlegen dass es mindestens google cloud so der weg wie man es da
macht du legst ein server template an und er stellt ihr dann quasi anhand der auslastung deines
eingangs weitere worker notes im hintergrund das ist auch eine coole sache aber du kannst das auch
mit polumi machen ich habe es gerade so abgetan wie ich würde das anders machen wenn ich da so
richtig drüber nachdenke für den einfachen fall was hoch zu skalieren ist das gar keine so doofe
idee ja man hat ein monitoring system überwacht wie viele requests kommen rein und sagt aha ich
müsste jetzt mal drei neue notes aufbauen das könnte man durchaus da einbauen drin warum nicht
die aus text ein fertiges programm ausspuckt
wie jetzt ach so ja du kannst du kannst ja gut du kannst den chat gpt reinschreiben ich
hätte gerne ein hello world in erlangen kannst du machen moin xeto moin fips alle am start ja du
warst lange nicht mehr da salto freak hat geradet mit drei leuten moin leute soll wir gucken jetzt
das video aber fertig an ich brauche da schon wieder ewig für mann habe richtig 21 jahre
nämlich bei 120.000 dollar im jahr im durchschnitt ja das wie gesagt also das mit chef mich wundert
dass das überhaupt da drinne vorkommt und wo ich schon gerade von depth obs sprechen da steckt ja
ob es drin ja das heißt die macht auch operations also server administration haltet euch da an
klassisches server hosting also colocation nicht cloud nicht aws sonst gar nichts einfach colocation
da sind die gehälter nämlich bei 111.000 dollar im durchschnitt
ja es ist jetzt auch schwer ok es ist wirklich schwer da was rauszulesen
es ist es ist ja wirklich schwer da was rauszulesen irgendwo
keine ahnung ich mein gut wenn man zuständig ist offline für hardware rechenzentrum und
sowas da gehört auch einiges dabei
am besten ist aber natürlich man blickt bei beidem durch ganz ehrlich ich würde mich heute
nicht darauf beschränken zu sagen ich mache nur cloud sachen mit echter hardware muss ich mich
überhaupt nicht mehr auskennen oder ich muss mich überhaupt nicht mehr mit netzwerkgrundlagen
beschäftigen weil dass er irgendwie alles automatisch für mich gehandelt wird also ganz
ehrlich es spricht doch überhaupt nichts dagegen sich mit beidem zu beschäftigen weil realistisch
betrachtet wenn man jetzt nicht bei einer ganz kleinen klitsche ist also bei kleinen klitschen
ist es halt eher so die haben den server irgendwo in der ecke stehen und das war es oder sie haben
alles ss service und das war es aber realistisch betrachtet ist es eigentlich immer so dass du
gewissen teil offline was heißt offline offline muss es ja nicht sein lokal vor ort stehen hast
und auch zunehmend sachen in der cloud also es ist eigentlich gar nicht entweder oder deswegen
ergibt diese liste für mich jetzt wenig sind aber selbst du kannst doch in der regel auch moment
das sind ja zwei komplett unterschiedliche paar schuhe leute mal ein bisschen musik anmachen
ne das das nicht das sind zwei unterschiedliche paar schuhe also bei größeren unternehmen die
ein rechenzentren betreiben ist es meistens gar nicht mehr so dass die admin selbst ins
rechenzentrum gehen unter irgendwelche sachen einbauen da hast du extra leute für früher war
das so wo ich auch beim provider gearbeitet habe ich habe es euch ja erzählt ich bin regelmäßig
morgens in frankfurt rund gegangen durch alle rechenzentren hat mir alles angeguckt ich habe
erkannt wenn dort ein orangenes lichtchen leuchtet versus gestern ein grünes es hat auch einen sehr
weihnachtlichen anblick gehabt im dunklen ich bin ja immer im dunklen durchs durchs rechenzentrum
gelaufen habe ich glaube ich auch erzählt also ich bin morgens früher als ich noch mal ein
provider gearbeitet habe in frankfurt morgens rein 7 uhr 8 uhr irgendwie 7 uhr 45 oder irgendwie
sowas nicht nicht 7 uhr 15 7 uhr 15 er war das wäre ja mal saumäßig früh damals 7 uhr 15
bin ich da rein da bin ich erst mal ins rechenzentrum im keller ins rechenzentrum dann
drüben anderen standard ins rechenzentrum oben dann bei der anderen seite wieder in keller bin
ich überall rumgelaufen hat mir die systeme angeguckt ja ob da irgendwas kaputt gegangen ist
über nacht kann ja durchaus sein was was jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt direkt siehst oder
direkt merkt vielleicht bevor es kaputt geht es ist auf jeden fall gut da mal ein blick rein zu
werfen und ich bin immer im dunklen rechenzentrum im keller ja wir hatten zwei im keller und eins
bisschen höheren gebäude im ob sechsten fünften oder sechsten stock war das und ich bin immer im
dunklen durchs rechenzentrum gelaufen erstens war das morgens angenehmer im dunklen durchs
rechenzentrum zu laufen und zwar jetzt haben wir die sachen besser gesehen und ich fand das
irgendwie eine angenehme atmosphäre durch durch dunkle rechenzentren zu laufen die waren ja nie
so dunkel da sind ja ganz viele lämpchen die waren ja nie so dunkel dass du irgendwie genau
wegen face liegt die waren ja nie so dunkel dass du nichts gesehen hast ja das hatten wir in der
theorie hatten wir das damals auch du hast mitbekommen wenn eine festplatte kaputt gegangen war du hast
mitbekommen wenn er wenn der lüfter kaputt war aber ich hatte trotzdem ein ruhigeres gefühl wenn
ich einmal am tag reingeguckt habe ich habe zum beispiel öfters sachen gesehen dass kabel nicht
richtig eingesteckt waren hat irgendeiner was umge umgebaut umgeschickt umgesteckt aber kabel
nicht richtig drin klar kannst du sagen hey wenn du das alles richtig überwachst ist das kein
problem aber es gibt ja durchaus den fall dass du beispielsweise switchen miteinander verbunden
hast über mehrere wege wenn ein kabel fehlt merkt man das erst mal gar nicht klar du kannst
natürlich monitor haben auf die port zwar um ist der port da unten sollte nicht da uns sein aber
wirklich alles 100 prozentig zu erkennen ist schwierig ich hatte zum beispiel öfters gesehen
als kabel nicht eingesteckt waren was denn das wie kann das sein hat irgendjemand eingebaut hat
eine sache nicht angeschlossen ich habe auch schon öfters gehört dass lüfter komische geräusche
gemacht haben eine ganze weile vor die lüfter kaputt gegangen sind da hat ibm damals immer
gesagt so nach dem motto was ist die fru nummer des lüfters als jemand was mit dem ibm support
zu tun hat die fru nummer fru nummer ist so was wie hardware nummer von einzelnen bauteilen und
ibm wollte immer die fru nummer von bauteilen wissen und du wusstest die fru nummer nicht
weil dich aufmachen konntest musst du sie in die datenbank gucken und was gab es sonst noch für
dinger ja ich habe auch ich habe öfter festgestellt dass irgendwelche discs kaputt waren natürlich
aber das rebuild hast du meistens gesehen das ist auf jeden fall eine gute also finde ich immer noch
eine gute sache und das sollte auch den rechenzentrum betreiber regelmäßig machen einfach mal durch
gehen und sich das ganze angucken du hast zwar monitoring du solltest die sachen mit mitbekommen
aber manche sachen kann sich nicht immer darauf verlassen dass du 100 prozent alles abgedeckt
hast mit überwachung der neue job der fängt am ersten vierten erst an viel replace mit unit
heißt das aber nur nummer was findest du besser virtuelle oder physik physische server das ist
ungefähr wie wenn ich dich frage was findest du besser hände oder füße also das kommt auf
den anwendungszweck an weder das eine noch das andere kann ich dir nicht sagen
ich weiß ja nicht mal was mit level admin sein soll und von windows administration habe ich noch
wenige ahnung müssen das video jetzt mal fertig gucken sonst wird das heute echt nicht pro jahr
ein junior mehr alter senior ich habe keine ahnung was ein senior was ein senior windows administrator
verdient ich kann dir sagen was ein linux was ein senior linux administrator oder sorry sorry ein
senior linux engineer was muss ja cool sein kann ich sagen was der verdient er verdient 92k im
jahr plus bonus plus bereitschaftszulage was dann im endeffekt so auf 105 bis 110k im jahr
rausläuft kann ich dir nämlich aus eigener hand sagen weil das habe ich letztens erst
unterschrieben wie das bei windows aussieht habe ich keine ahnung aber ich vermute mal windows wird
nicht viel anders sein wenn du eben wirklich auch gut was kannst und was kann es was gebraucht wird
gerade in frankfurt im finanzsektor geht da einiges an kohle
ja und ja ist es aber trotzdem ich mein das kann passieren ich hatte das öfters ich hatte öfters
dass sowohl sfp module nicht richtig drinne waren die lassen sich relativ einfach einfach
rausziehen gerade wenn man die hebel da hängen bleibt ich hatte aber auch schon das kram nicht
richtig eigentlich ja klar kannst du sagen das ist frusch was auch irgendwo stimmt aber ich mein
willst du dich drauf verlassen dass immer jeder alles perfekt macht und deswegen musst du nicht
mal drauf gucken also ich glaube nicht dass das der richtige ansatz ist du kannst nicht alles 100
prozent monitoren du kannst auch nicht davon ausgehen dass alle immer 100 prozent die sagen
richtig machen deswegen ist es nicht verkehrt einmal im tag in sein rechenzentrum reinzugucken
und das kann ja auch für den admin team oder für den operating team oder was auch immer oder sei
es sei es nur dafür die wie auch immer man jetzt irgendwelche hardware abteilung nennt kann er
nicht zu viel verlangt sein dass sie mal ins rechenzentrum gehen wo die kisten stehen für die
sie zuständig sind einmal am tag drauf gucken fertig das ganze ist natürlich nur so halb ernst
gemeint wir sehen hier allerdings einen gewissen trend die gehälter sind wahnsinnig gestiegen das
liegt aber aber auf der anderen seite sind auch wahnsinnig wertvoll für ein unternehmen und das
wissen mittlerweile beide deswegen sage ich ja leute darf sich da nicht unter wert verkaufen in
einem job in dem man die sagen die alle die sagen die alle das ist aber drüber und das gibt die
gehaltsspanne nicht her oder woanders kriegen sie auch nicht mehr die erzählen die alle viel
mist wenn der tag lang ist jogginghose im eigend zu hause bleiben kann und sogar noch spaß bei der
arbeit haben kann sind solche löhne wirklich angenehm ja kann man so sein kommentate in bereich
der datenbanken dürfte die sprache keine große überraschung sein die ganz ganz vorne ist
hoffentlich nicht oracle please nicht oracle zeug vorne standard und wird das auch bleiben
die sollte jeder können viel spannender sind da allerdings die database management systemen das
heißt die dinger die eure datenbanken verwalten die software hinten dran und hier ist das erste
mal ein anderer auf platz eins zu sehen in den jahren war immer mai sql die meistgenutzte
datenbank dieses jahr ist das in prozent nach gott sei dank alter endlich mal und das
zurecht wir nutzen sie auch rund einen vergleich wer von euch hat jetzt einen ganz kurzen moment
gedacht warum steht der sq lite was hat sq lite mit professionellen umfeld zu tun wer hat das auch
ganz kurz gedacht das ist aber zu kurz gedacht das hat sehr wohl was mit professionellem umfeld
zu tun weil es geht ja nicht darum quasi professionelle datenbank cluster zu betreiben
sondern professionelles umfeld heißt ja auch tool entwicklung desktop anwendungen vielleicht
auch kleinere web backends und sowas und da ist sq lite das beste was es gibt sq lite ist easy
lässt sich mit der anwendung ausliefern ist schnell hat sau viele funktionen sq lite hat
eine volltext suche und sowas also es ist gar nicht mal so dass sq lite jetzt irgendwie so abgespeckt
und mega kacke wäre das einzige wo sq lite kacke ist ist bei simultanen zugriffen aber
gut das hast du ja bei solchen anwendungen meistens also bei simultanen zugriffen wurden auch
simultan also gleichzeitig versucht wird zu schreiben und sowas da ist sq lite ein bisschen doof die
haben dann auch probleme mit müssen falls gelockt werden und sowas ist es dann nicht so schön aber
solange es nur lesen ist oder solange es halt einfach nur für eine desktop anwendung ist oder
irgendwas wo nicht viele leute darauf zu gehen ist sq lite ganz tolle sache beste was es gibt
ja die meisten android ich glaube sogar jede android anwendung hat sq lite datenbank hinten
dran zum speichern von daten ich glaube das muss so nicht ich bin mir da nicht sicher ich
habe noch in der an in der ios anwendung gemacht ich glaube du musst diese sql datenbank für
android gar nicht von hand managen das kannst du über die system apis machen dann kannst du
wahrscheinlich aber ich glaube es hat jede android anwendung sq lite mit dabei
wollte mir paperless im docker auf sein soll ich es können oder posten ganz ehrlich wenn du das
alleine verwendest kannst du ohne probleme das mit sq lite machen da brauchst du keinen zusätzlichen
datenbank container mehr und das funktioniert einfach alles du solltest halt gucken dass du
die dass du die sq lite datenbank auf irgendeinem volume oder auf irgendeinem mount hast wo du
sie auch gescheit backappen kannst also nicht hinter im container und so nach dem motto container
weg datenbank weg wie ist die geschwindigkeit von sq lite genauso schnell wie von einem anderen
system wenn du das richtige damit machst also es ist jetzt nicht so als würde sagen das kann man
sich auch in benchmarks angucken also es ist jetzt nicht so als wäre sq lite deutlich langsamer als
post das war das gegenteil sogar das gegenteil sq lite ist in manchen bereichen sogar deutlich
schneller als postgres wenn man sie eben für den richtigen fall einsetzt wenn man jetzt ganz viele
rights machen will oder schreibt zu vorgänge von mehreren usern aus parallel dann ist sq lite kacke
aber lokal sachen lesen in der datenbank lesen aus der datenbank oder auch mal lokal schreiben in der
datenbank sq lite super ist wahrscheinlich schneller du hast lokal eine sq lite auf der ssd liegen ist
höchstwahrscheinlich schneller als network access über socket über über eine leitung irgendwo
anders hin und sei es auf einen anderen container auf dem postgres also es spricht überhaupt nichts
dagegen sq lite zu verwenden sq lite ist super für das wofür es halt letztendlich ausgelegt ist
ja ja spricht da überhaupt nichts dagegen ist ja nicht so dass wir als hätte home assistant jetzt
ganz viele parallele rights und sowas
ne das muss man nicht manche leute empfehlen dass ich weiß nicht warum also ich habe mittlerweile
glaube ich habe ich nicht habe ich nicht ich habe es mir mal überlegt weil ich die sachen dann
besser in besser mit grafana glaube ich auswerten könnte aber ich habe es ich gucke mal ich glaube
ich habe das nicht umgestellt kurz in meine konfig gucken hier auf dem zweiten monitor ja ja ich
truste dem autor auch doch ich habe umgestellt auf auf maria db tatsächlich habe ich
ich habe auf maria db umgestellt das war dass ich das besser auswerten konnte und weil ich
längere history haben wollte genau ich wollte 180 tage history haben und habe mir gehofft dass
es ein bisschen besser performt was es wahrscheinlich machen wird würde ich nicht kann es genauso gut
auf sql bleiben was würdest du zum cashing empfehlen
das einfachste ist in memory die sachen zu cashen also wenn du nur wenn du nur eine
backend anwendung hast also eine anwendung für sich genommen
was spricht gegen in memory cache es ist es steht es es hängt immer davon ab was man machen will
leute das kann man so pauschal nicht sagen ich meine reddit dürfte so der klassiker sein für
solche die value cashing geschichten
das kann man immer nicht unabhängig vom anwendungszweck sagen wir nutzen sie auch
und einen vergleich habe ich bereits gemacht keine änderungen gab es bei den plätzen danach
sql mssql mongo db radis maria db beliebt sind aber vor allem bei den leuten können
euch noch dran erinnern wo die ganzen no sql dudes damals den tot der normalen datenbanken
vorausgesagt haben lulul relationale datenbanken wer verwendet dann so was mongo db no sql alter
vergisst diesen klassischen scheiß in ein paar jahren alles no sql doch nicht das ist
halt wieder der fall es kommt auf den anwendungsfall an in manchen sachen ist
no sql eine super geschichte manchen sachen ist halt so was ganz klassisches so mit verknüpfung
untereinander auch nicht schlecht wirklich benutzen posto sql und radis stinkt immer mehr ab was
vermutlich für viele auch ein grund für den wechsel ist am unbeliebtes db 2 das kann ich
verstehen lasst uns aber mal nach dem newcomer für dieses jahrausschau halten dazu werfen wir
zunächst einen blick auf den tiobindex denn da gibt es so schön plätze die einfach angezeigt
werden im vergleich zum letzten jahr haben sich ein kleines bisschen verändert php ist nach oben
gerutscht weil es eine neue version der sprache gibt die ziemlich viele moderne sachen mitbringt
und leute müssen wir uns mal wieder php angucken in nächster zeit wenn es eine neue version gibt
habe lange nichts mehr mit lara welle gemacht das wird mal glaube ich wieder zeit für eine
runde php was sagt ihr php
ich glaube so oldschool ist php gar nicht mehr
warum ist go so selten so selten ist das ist der programm das ist das ist irgendwie diese dieser
programmierbücher index den kannst du vergessen in den anderen umfragen war goh doch eigentlich
immer ganz gut dabei
natürlich server side rendering er wenn schon php dann richtig wobei nicht quatschen was erzähle
ich denn wir können unser backend mit php machen und dann machen wir irgendeine welt anwendung
vorne drauf oder so und objektiv sie schleichen sich auch einige plätze nach vorn objektiv sie
vermutlich deshalb weil swift insgesamt gefallen ist und die beiden im apple cosmos ein bisschen
das entweder oder sind spannend für mich also an sprachen sind vor allem rast und go lustigerweise
genau die sprachen die bei mir im letzten jahr auf dem lernzettel standen und dieses jahr auf
dem tutorials zettel stehen und das deckt sich übrigens auch mit stack overflow rast ist nun
das siebte jahr in folge die meist geliebte programmiersprache und mittlerweile wohl auch
wirklich in einem lasing fast stabilen zustand in dem sie auch von 8,8 freuen sich dann alle
crustaceans 10 professionellen entwicklern schon verwendet wird go hat sogar noch ein paar mehr
professionelle entwickler mit knapp zwölf prozent trotzdem nicht ganz so viele fans man muss hier
aber auch wirklich sagen dass kann ich verstehen also für mich ist go tatsächlich 50 50 es hat
paar coole sachen es hat ein paar sehr coole libraries es gibt aber auch sachen die mir
nicht gefallen die anwendungsfälle sich schon ziemlich unterscheiden rast konzentriert sich
auf hohe performance und zeitgleich eine niedrige fehlerquote wenn der code läuft es ist das ziel
bei rast dass wenn der code läuft dann soll es am besten fehlerfrei sein das heißt schon bevor
das wäre was für unseren das wäre was für mein ehemaliger zu wie gewesen maxes kompiliert also
muss es auch richtig funktionieren kann man das meiste im debugging machen und das ist natürlich
super wenn man einfach sachen rausbringen kann die wahrscheinlich nicht abstürzen trotzdem soll
aber auch die geschwindigkeit und das umfeld mit dem von c plus bloß verglichen werden und das macht
die sprache besonders als nachfolger im hardware nahen umfeld ganz ehrlich das rast ökosystem ist
so viel angenehmer als c plus plus allein schon dass so ein ordentlichen ordentlichen package
manager ist es ist ja noch nicht mal ein eigenes ja noch besser in rast es ist kein eigener package
manager es ist quasi das gesamte bild package management config tool ist da direkt dabei du
hast cargo mit cargo testest du bildest du installierst pakete konfigurierst den ganzen
scheiß also das rast ökosystem ist so viel angenehmer als irgendwelche komischen header
müll aus c plus plus und jetzt kommt mir keiner mit module an bist du mal module sinnvoll
verbreitet überall in c plus plus verwenden kannst es 2033 oder so interessant go ist ebenfalls
eine kompilierbare sprache allerdings mit focus auf web cluster und cloud und skalierung das sind
beides wichtige themen in der nächsten zeit und dementsprechend glaube ich dass beide sprachen
auch nächstes jahr wieder ein bisschen ansteigen werden so lange c plus plus nicht ansteigt ist
alles ok und welche technologie im unternehmen benutzt wird das bedingt sich oft selbst trotzdem
kann man sich zumindest bei der wahl der technologie ein bisschen vorbereiten da man sonst ohnehin
umschulen muss im deft job scanner wurde eine analyse des job markts durchgeführt für it
beziehungsweise für entwickler nicht nur arbeiten die meisten entwickler mit javascript auch
nicht verwunderlich zent aller job angebote sind für javascript auch nicht wirklich verwunderlich
fast ein drittel da macht etwa 18 prozent aus also immer noch ordentlich viel klassisches java mit
15 prozent im dritten platz sie schafft zwölf prozent danach kommen php und nach cc plus plus und
ruby wirklich dünn das insgesamt also diese sprachen decken nämlich schon mehr als 95 prozent ab
alles in allem können wir also mitnehmen die meisten von uns arbeiten im web umfeld und arbeiten mit
javascript und all den frameworks die dann dazu kommen python ist nach wie vor überall rast und
go sind auf dem vormarsch genauso wie kafka das auch im webbereich eine große community
mittlerweile findet wenn ich so mit euch sprechen dann bestätigt ihr mir all das desktop apps
sterben aus dafür werden websites und apps weiterentwickelt beziehungsweise neu entwickelt
und wir werden allesamt überdurchschnittlich gut bezahlt zumindest wenn wir nicht selbstständig
sind gleichzeitig fallen aber auch die meisten jobs auf nur vier programmier sprachen die sollten
sich also definitiv in eurem repertoire befinden diese und auch die meisten frameworks oder
nichigeren technologien findet ihr bereits bei mir als tutorial geht dazu am besten direkt auf die
bootstrap academy und dann hat es so eine art message q dies übersichtlicher als youtube ein paar
sachen fehlen mir allerdings noch zum beispiel kafka deswegen meine frage an euch was sind eure
technologien für 2023 welche sprachen wollt ihr unbedingt lernen und vor allem welche technologien
auch schreibt mir das bitte also ich kann es euch sagen ich werde mir auf jeden fall noch ein
bisschen mehr google cloud angucken und ich werde mir auch noch ein bisschen mehr kubernetes zeug
angucken wenn ich kann das meiste damit zwar machen aber wirklich jetzt also ich kann was ich
kann ein deployment machen ja und ich kann dafür sorgen dass ich irgendwie von fünf auf zehn potts
es sind ja potts da werde ich container sagen auch wenn meistens ein pot gleich ein container aber
es muss ja nicht so sein es könnte ja auch sein dass da noch irgendwelche nodexporter mit dabei
laufen was auch immer kann ich kann ich machen das funktioniert aber wirklich großartige ahnung im
detail habe ich von kubernetes eigentlich nicht also wenn da was kaputt geht würde ich mir
unglaublich schwer tun das wieder zum laufen zu bringen zum glück brauche man das beim
manage kubernetes cluster nicht aber ja und vor allem google cloud muss ich mir ein bisschen mehr
noch angucken doch auch gescheit macht es ohne beruflichen hintergrund sind mich komplett mit
kubernetes zu beschäftigen es macht immer sinn sich damit zu beschäftigen wenn es dich interessiert
vergisst du die alten dinge nicht wieder das ist eine gute frage das kann man so pauschal
nicht beantworten ja ich vergesse die dinge aber ich habe die meisten sachen auch so weit im
kopf dass wenn ich sie dann wieder brauche dass ich meistens relativ schnell wieder finde also
ist nicht so dass jetzt beispielsweise zum beispiel ich habe als type script neu war mal auch ein
paar wochen sehr viel type script gemacht weil ich es cool fand dass der ehemalige c-sharp chef
jetzt javascript verbessern wird und so was ich habe jetzt jahrelang kein type script mehr gemacht
mache eigentlich wenn wir web sachen machen das ganz klassischen javascript aber wenn ich jetzt
wieder type script machen müsste würde ich wahrscheinlich von den basics relativ schnell
wieder reinkommen und viele sachen kommen mir dann auch bekannt vor ja oder auch irgendwelche
irgendwelche immer microcontroller es ist ich bastel nicht jedes jahr in irgendwelchen
esps und auch eigene firmware und so was rum aber wenn ich mal wieder machen muss da komme ich
ganz gut rein da weiß ich ok da war doch jetzt ach wie hieß das noch mal zum initialisieren vom
netzwerk da weiß ich wenigstens schon nach was ich suchen muss also bringt schon was ich kann mir
natürlich nicht alles merken das kann keiner selbst 250 eq leute soll das funktionen du kannst
nicht alles merken aber du merkst es auf jeden fall ob du dich schon mal mit was beschäftigt
hast oder ganz neu anfängt das ist wirklich ein unterschied auch wenn man zwei drei jahre oder
noch länger nicht gemacht hat wie gesagt ich könnte heute immer noch das beispiel von vorhin
aufzugreifen ich könnte heute wahrscheinlich immer noch im half life 1 level editor eine relativ
ansehnliche map bauen auch wenn das keiner mehr braucht und das schon 15 jahre oder so
hierher ist länger fack alda das ist 23 jahre her hast du noch kontakt zu allen utopasen krieger
solution selten also krieger habe ich lange nicht mehr gesprochen ganz kurz vor vor ein paar
monaten geschrieben im solution habe ich vor einem jahr oder so mal kurz ein bisschen was
geschrieben nee also selten wenig wenig auf jeden fall ja orchestrierung für home lab ich ich bin
der meinung im home lab brauchst du es nicht wirklich also im home lab brauchst du definitiv
kein kubernetes kubernetes sich damit beschäftigen wenn es einen interessiert macht auf jeden fall
sind weil ich mein wenn du in dem bereich arbeitest es gibt so ein paar sachen die sind nicht schlecht
zu wissen sich mit container auszukennen mal irgendwie so was die pleute haben in kubernetes
ein bisschen ahnung von javascript html css und es gibt so paar sachen die sind auf jeden fall nicht
verkehrt auch wenn man jetzt vielleicht in einem ganz anderen bereich ist hilft es vielleicht
stell dir vor du bist anwendungsentwickler beschäftigt sich ein bisschen mit kubernetes
dann hilft es vielleicht deine anwendungen besser zu bauen dass sie sich besser kontinuieren lassen
und besser als container load workload funktionieren also ist nicht verkehrt für daheim also
orchestrierung im home lab und so was vergisst es braucht kein mensch es gibt diesen kerl auf
youtube den wir manchmal gucken der mit seinem rack und irgendwie fünf kubaletes cluster der
konnte ja bis heute nicht ordentlich erklären was er eigentlich damit macht außer dass er das hat
um sich selbst zu verwalten und noch mehr kisten die er dann selbst verwalten kann und weitere
kisten um die weiteren kisten zu verwalten macht macht eigentlich keinen sinn das ist einfach nur
overkill und willst ja nicht dass deine installation daheim noch ein zweiter job ist also dafür finde
ich das finde ich das bescheuert es gibt auch leute die automatisieren ihre kisten daheim mit
ansible oder oder gegen jahre vor allem mit terraform an oder was auch immer es ist bis zum
gewissen grad vielleicht sinnvoll was in ansible rein zu hauen wenn man ab und zu mal raspberry
pies installiert und immer wieder das gleiche drauf haut man kann man ansible playbook machen
aber darüber hinaus gehen finde ich ist das daheim overkill und macht wahrscheinlich mehr
arbeit als ich jemals auszahlen wird aber sich damit zu beschäftigen ist trotzdem sinnvoll
weiß ja nicht dass man es dahin verwenden muss bist du eigentlich mit einem mainboard zufrieden
ja bis jetzt schon keine probleme kennst du dich mit dem ganzen docker netzwerkeinstellungs aus
bridge merkwider ja das hatte nichts mit docker zu tun das ist ja bei kvm und unterlinungs generell
das ist ja alles das gleiche das hat es nicht direkt was mit docker zu tun ja ich weiß was
die unterschiede sind und das ist eigentlich ein super thema zu der frage hier oben ob ich
mir alles merken kann nein ich kann mir nicht alles merken ich könnte jetzt nicht 100 prozentig
aus dem kopf den unterschied sagen aber ich kann dir ein paar unterschiede sagen zum beispiel dass
eine bridge quasi ein virtueller switch ist den linux nachbaut mit allen eigenschaften also auch
dass alle systeme die an diesem switch angestöpselt werden miteinander kommunizieren
können verwendest du mcv lan dann ist das eine ganze ganze ecke tiefer das ist quasi kein
kompletter virtueller switch das ist eher so ein kleiner aufsatz auf deinem netzwerk treiber dann
hast du zum beispiel das problem dass du vom host zum container nicht kommunizieren kannst also
kannst beispielsweise nicht von dem host auf dem ein container läuft auf den container zugreifen
per netzwerk oder eben von deinem container auf services die auf dem host läuft was immer das
netzwerk da gibt es ip alles kann ich dir aus dem kopf nicht sagen aber ich wüsste jetzt was ich
suchen muss das ist ja eigentlich das wichtige dadurch dass man sich eine weile damit beschäftigt
hat findet man die sachen ziemlich schnell weil man weiß noch was man gucken muss ja das hängt
ab was du verwenden solltest das hängt davon ab was du brauchst wie so wie wie immer brauchst du
zugriff per netzwerk vom host auf den container vom container auf den host das einfachste ist
eine bridge zu verwenden da geht alles das aber auch quasi gleichzeitig das ressourcen intensivste
macht im heimbereich wahrscheinlich keinen unterschied aber solltest du da irgendwie
anwendung containerisiert haben die zehntausende den user drauf hat dann ist selbst das über den
docker proxy zu machen oftmals keine gute idee sondern dann ist vielleicht manchmal tatsächlich
host networking ganz sinnvoll kommt immer darauf an was man machen will ihr habt das spiel ist
ja neuer schein wurde richtig drauf gehype ist wahrscheinlich aber ich weiß gerade die aktuellen
releases nicht aus dem kopf also wo ich mich echt darauf freue ist die last of us serie zu
gucken hat jetzt mit spielen direkt nichts zu tun leider nur auf sky oder auf hbo max oder auf
wo oder so ich habe kein bock auf noch ein weiteres aber das entweder warte ich bis es
das irgendwo bei amazon zu kaufen gibt oder woanders zu gucken gibt oder ich lasse mein account
scheren oder ich gucke über vpn vielleicht irgendwie doch keine ahnung ich weiß nicht
ich meine es gibt ja auch noch auch noch andere möglichkeiten ja keine keine seiten hier posten
modc check
Da ist zwei, ist da eigentlich schon für den Sub?
Badgehe, ne noch nicht Badgehe.
Hast du schon das Fireship Video zu Kafka geschaut?
Ne.
Haha, Chaelor, ich hab gerade mal geguckt.
Leute, ich glaube der Chaelor ist der Spitzenreiter.
Der hatte schon ein Bann und 20 Timeouts.
Ich glaube so viel hat noch keiner geschafft.
Ups, jetzt hab ich auch falsch geklickt.
Nur wir können, wir können es erhöhen wenn du willst.
Du bist perma bunt bei Semper Video, wer weiß was du da getrieben hast.
Scheinlich zurecht.
Es ist gleich Badge Time, das ist korrekt Chat, das habt ihr gut erkannt.
Kafka in 100 Sekunden, okay Leute wir können uns was zum Thema angucken.
Kafka, warum immer so früh ins Bett, ne es gibt Leute die müssen arbeiten gehen am anderen Tag.
Ich kann hier nicht dem krassen Influencer Lifestyle frönen die ganze Zeit.
Okay, sobald Cluster und Broker und sowas kommen weiß man es ist schon wieder komplex zu betreiben.
Es gibt bestimmt mittlerweile schon Kafka as a Service und sowas.
Weil die meisten Leute keinen Bock haben selbst noch auszulösen.
Eins muss man ja sagen, denen geht die Namen für ihre komischen Services ja echt nicht
aus oder?
Ich weiß das gibt es schon eine Weile, aber gibt es eben so ein Generator für diese Dinge?
Ich weiß das gibt es schon eine Weile, aber gibt es eben so eine Weile, aber gibt es eben so eine Weile?
Ich weiß das gibt es schon eine Weile, aber gibt es eben so eine Weile, aber gibt es eben so eine Weile, aber gibt es eben so eine Weile?
Einer der Herausforderungen, die ich hatte, als ich mein eigenes Home Lab gebaut habe, war, ein gutes System zu finden, das ich auf meinen Home Servers runnen wollte.
Wenn du anfängst, Server Systeme zu suchen, findest du schnell heraus, wie viele verschiedene Lösungen existieren.
Wir haben alle verschiedenen Linux-Distributionen.
Oracle, genau, das ist das, was ich sagen wollte, Spotify, Oracle Linux, wegen bescheuerten Lizenzbedingungen.
Übrigens, neue, bescheuerte Lizenzbedingungen von Oracle, pass mal auf, wir hatten letztens einen Oracle Lizenzberater da, ja sowas braucht man da, und folgende Sache,
Oracle hat Oracle Unbreakable Linux nennt sich das übrigens, das heißt ja gar nicht Oracle Linux, das heißt da streng genommen gar nicht Oracle Linux,
sondern das heißt Oracle Unbreakable Linux, oder der Kernel heißt Unbreakable Kernel, das ist auch schon sehr, ja, bisschen weit aus dem Fenster geleht, dass das Unbreakable ist.
Zumindest, neue, super Sache von Oracle, also wir betreiben aktuell Oracle Datenbutton auf Oracle Linux, warum passiert das bei uns, wo ich gerade arbeite, ganz einfach,
nicht weil man es bräuchte, das würde ganz normal auch unter CentOS oder Red Hat laufen, sondern wir haben das nur, dass der Support sich nicht gegenseitig das in die Schuhe schieben kann.
Und stellt euch mal vor, man würde eine Oracle Datenbank auf Red Hat betreiben, dann sagt der Red Hat Support, ah das liegt an Oracle, und Oracle sagt, ah das liegt an Red Hat.
Wenn man jetzt allerdings Oracle auf Oracle betreibt, können die sich das intern gerne zuschieben und man kriegt schnelle Antworten.
Was natürlich ziemlich dämlich ist, dass man überhaupt sowas machen muss, für die tausende Euro, die man dort an Support bezahlt.
So, also wir haben Oracle Linux mit Oracle Datenbanken drauf, jetzt haben wir gesagt, ok, wie wäre es denn, wenn wir noch ein paar weitere Kisten mit Oracle Linux mal hinstellen.
Weil CentOS hat Probleme, CentOS gibt es in der aktuellen Form ja nicht mehr, echtes Red Hat, vielleicht Oracle, probieren wir es mal mit Oracle Linux testweise bei ein paar Kisten aus, kostet ja nix. So, und dann sagte dann der Oracle Typ, nee.
Oracle Linux kostet bei euch auch Lizenzgebühren, und wisst ihr warum? Weil Oracle eine Lizenz Matching Policy hat, das heißt, wenn du Kisten hast mit einem, mit Support Level X, dann müssen automatisch alle anderen Kisten, die du jemals installieren wirst, damit auch mindestens Support Level X haben.
Also wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel drei Oracle Kisten haben, mit Oracle Linux, Oracle Datenbanken drauf, die, keine Ahnung, 5000 Euro im Jahr Support Plan haben, und wir wollen jetzt noch 100 weitere Oracle Kisten daneben stellen, Oracle Linux Kisten daneben stellen, für andere Sachen, die eigentlich gar keinen Support bräuchten, dann sagt Oracle nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Nee, nee, nee, die anderen 100 Kisten brauchen auch jeweils den 5000 Euro Support Plan.
Jetzt ist tatsächlich die Frage, kündigen die einfach den Support, weil es billiger ist.
Ja, also Oracle ist wirklich absolut räudig, was das angeht.
Eigentlich gibt es, wie gesagt, eigentlich gibt es bloß, realistisch betrachtet gibt es für den Heimbereich eigentlich nur zwei Sachen zur Auswahl, Debian oder Ubuntu.
Ich finde sowohl Oracle, als auch Red Hat, als auch CentOS, als auch Alma Linux und solche Red Hat Abkömmlinge, Suse, ist im Heimbereich jetzt nicht so das, das ist sinnvoll, wenn du Support haben willst, oder wenn du was haben willst, was zertifizierte Software draufläuft, im Heimbereich ist es Debian oder Ubuntu fertig.
Ja, Alpine für Docker und sowas alles, alles gut, aber zumindest Debian, Debian und Ubuntu. Nein, wir reden vom Serverbetrieb nicht auf dem Desktop.
Das ist ja immer so.
Ah, erstmal Advertisement, okay wir skippen mal kurz das Advertisement, ich hoffe jetzt bin ich böse, dass ich das Advertisement skippe.
Okay, Windows streichen wir mal.
Bei allem hast du so viele Tutorials, das ist ja auch das, was den Raspberry Pi immer noch zur besten Plattform macht.
Ah, erstmal schön, das 10 Gigabit Interface, gesagt, ist eigentlich nicht im Serverbereich.
Also ganz im Ernst, ich glaube, es gibt sicherlich ein paar Verrückte, die kommen dann so an mit Slackware, Arch auf dem Server, oder dann kommen wieder andere an und sagen, hey hey, es muss doch ein BSD sein.
Aber realistisch betrachtet, CentOS Rated will sich im Heimbereich wahrscheinlich keiner richtig geben, also bleibt Debian und Ubuntu übrig, Susis sagt auch.
Okay, er hat insofern schon recht, es gibt bestimmt unterschiedliche Aussagen, aber es sind ja nur 5 Stück, die in Frage kommen.
Genau, das ist das, was ich ja auch schon auf dem Stream gesagt habe. Kommt drauf an.
Ich würde Ubuntu einfach ausprobieren, denn für mich ist Ubuntu immer noch mein Top 1 Linux-Distribution und ich empfehle es immer.
Das einzige Dumme an Ubuntu ist ihre komische, jammelbasierte Netzwerkkonfiguration. Was die Typen in Südafrika sich dabei gedacht haben, keine Ahnung.
Ubuntu hat für mich schon seit fast 15 Jahren auf meinen Servern super gearbeitet und das hat sich nicht wirklich über die Zeit verändert.
In den letzten Jahren, seit der Kontainerisierung ist, ist die Wahl von einer bestimmten Linux-Distribution als Unterlagen-System weniger wichtig geworden.
Inzwischen ist Snap inzwischen keine Ahnung, ich will den Mist aber so und so nicht verwenden.
Man kann auch einfach im Heimbereich ein stinknormales Docker-Compose-File hinlegen, wenn man wirklich was in der Richtung machen will.
Die übertreiben teilweise im Heimbereich so krass.
Es gibt viele Leute, die sich in Raspberry Pi frisch gekauft haben und dann die normale Installation drauf machen und da drüber ein bisschen klingen, aber sonst niemand, der dabei verstanden ist, installiert einen GUI auf dem Server.
Also in X oder sowas und dann wozu?
Das Einzige, was einen vollständigen Desktop drauf hat, waren früher unsere Datenbank-Server, weil irgendein Anbieter von irgendeiner Software, die da drauf war, gesagt hat, wir hätten gerne eine Red Hat-Vollinstallation und eine Red Hat-Vollinstallation war auch genau um dabei.
Du hast Herbstluft für Herbstluft.
Chelo, du weißt doch nicht mal, wie das richtig heißt. Hast du nicht auf deinem Server. Aber wenn du unbedingt eine GUI auf deinem Server haben willst, mach was du willst.
Du hast doch nie ein Windows Server Core in Production gesehen. Was ist Windows Server Core?
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es zwei Versionen oder mehrere Versionen von Windows Server gibt.
Ich weiß, früher gab es irgendwie. Ach, ohne GUI. Ja, Windows. Windows kannst du ja auch ohne GUI nicht gescheit bedienen.
Ich rede ja auch nicht von Windows, wenn ich sage, kein GUI. Also Windows würde ich schon mal prinzipiell nicht auf dem Server installieren.
Windows kannst du nicht bedienen ohne GUI. Das ist klar.
Kannst du nicht einfach auch Windows Core RDP installieren und dann hast du auf dem Server selbst einfach zwar alles installiert, aber der Server selbst startet in der PowerShell und hat nur ein GUI, wenn du remote dich drauf einloggst, was aber halt sinnlos ist, weil es ist trotzdem alles drauf und läuft.
WebUIs, das ist in Ordnung. Das kann man machen. Da spricht nichts dagegen. Ich bin kein großer Portainer-Fan, aber da spricht nichts dagegen. Das kann man machen.
Das wäre so nett, weil es wirklich den Unterschied in dem YouTube-Algorithm macht.
Wir ringen die Bälle.
In ein paar Worten ist Linux großartig.
Ich habe ihn abonniert. Ich kann das auch nur empfehlen. Er macht gute Videos. Ich bin aber nicht eingeloggt.
Was hältst du von Gento mit Custom-Kurlier? Kann man machen, aber nicht auf dem Server. Wozu?
Ich sage nur zu Windows.
Aber ich möchte immer ein bisschen im Gegensatz zu diesem Linux-Fanboy sein, denn Windows ist immer noch das meistgebrannte System.
Das ist eine sehr angenehme User-Experience auf dem Server als mit Windows.
Es gibt Leute, die zum Monitoring z.B. PRTG und solche Geschichten benutzen. Das ist glaube ich immer noch Windows-only.
Es gibt Leute, die es nicht gut für die Home-Server machen. Aber wenn du in Home-Labs und Tech-Stuff bist, solltest du auf die Home-Server schauen.
Und für einige Leute ist es gut, wenn man nicht auf einem Terminal ist oder eine sehr spezielle User-Experience hat.
Wenn ich dieses Ding schon sehe, kriege ich echt Anfälle. Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern, als wir das im Stream mal gemacht haben? Wir haben nochmal einen Windows-Server zusammen eingerichtet. Meine Güte, war das ein Krampf.
Ich habe hier noch einen Vergleich. Aber es ist ein schönes Side-Projekt, das man sich anschauen kann. Vielleicht nicht für dein eigenes Operierungssystem, sondern für eine Virtual-Maschine.
Das bringt mich übrigens zu den zweiten Lösungen, die ich mit dir sprechen möchte.
Wenn du wie ich und ich viele verschiedene Operierungssysteme und Applikationen testen möchtest, die alle auf einzelnen physischen Maschinen laufen, die sehr teuer und auch sehr teuer sind,
würdest du wahrscheinlich nur hunderts von verschiedenen Home-Servern kaufen. Und deswegen solltest du wirklich die Virtualisierung nutzen, wenn es möglich ist.
Das erlaubt dir, verschiedene Operierungssysteme auf einer einzelnen Maschine zu laufen.
Du musst also nicht nur ein Operierungssystem wählen und das wird dein Hauptsystem für immer. Du kannst es immer versuchen und testen.
Es ist halt KVM. Ja, Proxmox ist auch KVM.
Also unter Linus ist es eigentlich KVM. Natürlich könnte man den VirtualBox drauf machen oder VMWare Workstation oder was auch immer, aber wozu?
Also für die meisten Virtualisierungssachen ist KVM unter Linus einfach das Beste, was man nehmen kann.
Ob KVM Typ 1 oder Typ 2 ist, das kannst du dir selber beantworten. Ich sage dir nur, du kannst GPU-Pastru darin machen.
Es gibt in meiner Meinung nachher bessere Plattformen, die nur für diese eine Aufgabe gemacht werden.
Denn KVM auf der Suche zu laufen benötigt eine Menge, die für Software und Packages verwendet werden müssen.
Du musst sie installieren und managen. Du brauchst natürlich eine Virtualisierung.
Vielleicht möchtest du eine Interface haben, die du leichter managen und neue KVM kreieren kannst.
Oder du musst Snapshots nehmen, Backups konfigurieren und Monitoren machen.
Und das kann alles sehr schrecklich sein, um zu setzten.
Versteh dich unter Linux, weil ich es vorher schon probiert habe.
Das war eigentlich der Grund, warum ich Ubuntu direkt auf meinen Home-Server-Hardware stoppte.
Als ich etwas mehr in Virtual-Machine-Management und Storage-Pools begonnen habe...
Aber da ist jetzt nicht wie bei ESX oder so ein ordentliches Web-Interface dabei.
Da ist natürlich was zusätzliches, was mit einem Interface wie Proxmox ist ganz nett.
Sowas wie Unraid ist auch durchaus okay.
Deswegen finde ich das im Heimbereich mittlerweile wirklich schön verkehrt.
Du kannst sowas wie Cockpit genau installieren.
Aber Cockpit ist noch rudimentärer als Wirt-Manager.
Was ist das, Leute?
Habt ihr eine Ahnung, was das ist?
Ist das Zutrix?
Ist das Xen?
Xen hat ja noch ein anderes Logo.
Was ist das da?
Was ist das Logo?
Das ist Xen.
Linux oder vielleicht ein Windows-Server auf dem Topf.
Jedoch, das ist natürlich ein Problem.
Eine weitere Frage.
Welche Hypervisor-Plattform ist dann der beste für eure Home-Server?
Und ich möchte nur ein paar Lösungen zufügen, die ich in der Vergangenheit mitgearbeitet habe.
Und ich möchte auch sagen, was ich jetzt benutze.
Zum Beispiel gibt es die Microsoft Hyper-V, die jetzt gratis ist.
Und du kannst sie einfach mit all den Typen von Verkaufs-Maschinen benutzen.
... System wie Linux-Server oder andere Windows-Server.
Ich habe mit der Microsoft Hyper-V in der Anfang meiner IT-Apprenticeship gearbeitet.
Wir hatten ein paar kleine und medium-sized-Business, in denen wir nur...
Nee, es ist nicht entweder oder.
Eigentlich, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Unter Windows 10 geht das sogar.
Du kannst offiziell sogar Vmware und Hyper-V zusammenlaufen lassen.
Da gibt es mittlerweile Settings für Vmware.
Das Problem ist nur, dass es rumbackt.
Es sollte zwar theoretisch gehen, aber es funktioniert praktisch gesehen hat, richtig.
... System, um mehrere Serven zu virtualisieren.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich mag es nicht sehr.
Denn im Vergleich zu anderen Hypervisor-Plattformen ist die Microsoft Hyper-V ein bisschen limited.
Ich mag auch Hyper-V nicht.
Und das sage ich, obwohl ich Hyper-V nie richtig verwendet habe.
Allein schon, weil ich Windows unten drunter brauche.
... Interadministrate.
Wat I've also been working with during that time was VMware und the Hypervisor ESX.
Vmware ist, wenn du nichts anderes brauchst als VMs laufen zu lassen, ist ESX, meiner Meinung nach wirklich das Beste.
Sowohl vom Management her, auch von der Oberfläche her.
Es ist ein bisschen Wissenschaft für sich, aber ganz im Ernst.
ich persönlich wenn ich wirklich nur vms bräuchte und sonst sonst nix dann
würde ich es extra auf machen warum ich es nicht gemacht haben ja gut ganz
einfach ich habe andere anforderungen ich lasse zum größten teil container
laufen also ich habe ungefähr so 12 13 container laufen mittlerweile auf
meinem auf meinem unrate
ich will ich grad
was ist denn da was ist alles drauf zertifikate reverse proxy ist drauf
also ich muss mal kurz drauf gucken
ich komme hier nicht auf mein unrate drauf keckel
so die so die bei so die basic standards sachen ein home assistant
der ist in der vm blut sind ich was habe ich denn auf ich ja ich habe einen teile
so so elektronik teile sortier system drauf und doku wie geht drauf laufen
zertifikate bennett schwänz für letzte encrypt zeug drauf laufen
ich funktioniert einfach deswegen fällt es mir jetzt irgendwie nicht ein
es sind so zwölf 13 dinger so und ich habe allerdings noch tatsächlich zwei
vms drauf laufen nämlich einmal für zabbix
war mir in dem fall lieber tatsächlich komplett eigen ist eine vm für zabbix
und eine vm für home assistant
das ist halt was das kannst du im es ich so nicht ohne weiteres machen weil da
bräuchtest du eine vm und in dieser vm wird sie dann einen ganzen
container laufen lassen beispielsweise die frage an was nimmt für eine
oberfläche dafür ist management wenn du einfach nur ganz sinnlos irgendwie
zwölf dinger anschmeißen willst ohne dich groß damit zu beschäftigen aber du
bräuchte sagen dann wieder eine eigene vm für kein problem dann hast du wieder
das problem hardware passt du also ich möchte ja ich möchte ja
beispielsweise wenn ich im file server laufen lasse oder sowas dann braucht es
ja ordentlich performance was du in der regel nur hast wenn du wirklich dann
auch die hardware durch reichst an die vm dann müsstest du dann den kompletten
dann müsstest du quasi den kompletten das controller oder sonstige durch
reichen in die vm dann hast du dann wieder das ding hast es in der vm da
musst du da drin irgendwie von hand deine samba konfig machen also reines
reines virtualisierung ist tatsächlich für so ein heim anwendungs gefällt ja
ich habe eine eigene next cloud ich mag next cloud aber nicht aber ich habe
immer noch next cloud für den kalender sonst verwende ich eigentlich nahezu
nichts von next cloud reine virtualisierung ist da mir ein
bisschen zu wenig deswegen finde ich so sachen wie proxmox tatsächlich im
heimbereich auch ganz nice da kann man container und vm nebeneinander
laufen lassen und vms nebeneinander laufen lassen wobei ich tatsächlich
sagen muss ich habe jetzt ein bisschen rum getestet ich habe früher android
immer so ein bisschen trash talked ich finde es mittlerweile tatsächlich ganz
praktisch
so einfache sachen daheim side that you will probably see often in the
enterprise field in a data center for example für vms wäre mir es x immer
noch am liebsten smaller environments you can work with the free vm vero
hypervisor e6 i it is a great solution for virtualization however i have to say
that is also a system that i personally wouldn't run on a home server because a
lot of the advanced features of vm vero are licensed and they can't be used on
the free version of e6 i for example i like to automate the deployment of my
virtual machines with terraform and this requires right access to the api of the
hypervisor which is not possible in the free version of e6 i and i just don't
like messing around with this complicated stuff or just other smaller things like
the old ok bei terraform daheim ist vielleicht auch schon ein bisschen kann man sich jetzt
weh vom vm vero a long time ago in my opinion there is a better alternative
hypervisor platform existing that is just perfect for personal home servers and
you can get it completely for free for most of you guys it won't be surprising
because it's proxmox which is an open source solution based on linux and kvm
it allows you to visualize all sorts of workloads yeah you can even put it has
some nice features for managing storage and containers and it is really great
with automation for example i've recently made a video about how to automate
virtual machine deployments with proxmox terraform and packer where all my vms
are now defined as code that allows me to spin up new servers with pre-installed
packages and configurations in just about a few seconds that is cool
es ist es ist cool muss ich aber fragen wie oft macht man eine neue vm
also ich lege äußerst selten auf meinem heimserver neue vms an
ich habe da jetzt meine ubuntu kiste mit subx drin und ich habe mein homo
system und das ist halt ein paar monaten so und da hat sich nichts mehr getan
also ich gette dass das cool ist dass alles in terraform zu haben und auch cool
ist da mal was neues anzuwerfen ansonsten wenn ich irgendwas
ausprobieren will mache ich eigentlich nahezu immer auf dem desktop in forever
workstation aber es hat was es ist cool es hat auch einen weiteren vorteil man
kann nachgucken was man da drauf hat was man damit was man damit eingerichtet hat
das ist halt super wenn du es in terraform hast dann siehst du ok genau was
es ist gut konfig kannst in terraform nicht so sehr übertreiben
also konfig management über terraform ist ist abfuck das willst du nicht du
kannst cloud in it machen das war's alles was über cloud in it hinausgeht
und da irgendwie zwei drei zeilen custom script noch innen drinne ist
nicht so wirklich praktikabel da bräuchte es dann auch so was wie n simple
zusätzlich dann artet es für einen heimbereich wieder aus aber so absolut
so oft macht es auch in einem bereich nichts neues
functionality or metrics logging that you can integrate into your monitoring
solution but even if you're just starting to explore visualization as a
beginner proxmox is very intuitive to use it has a nice and clean web
interface that you can easily use to create new virtual machines add
containers or storages manage backups and snapshots all that stuff is really
very straightforward and once you start playing around with it a bit more you're
going to love all the advanced features that you can use like cloud in it create
vm templates and deploy them free API all the time that I've used proxmox it
hasn't disappointed me so when I would need to pick one favorite operating
system for my home servers I would say it's proxmox there's just one problem you
might run into when you try to install it in a smaller home lab because it
doesn't work on ARM based CPUs like a raspberry I've seen there is a similar
project around that's called py mox but I also ich glaube die meisten leute
werden auf raspberry pi keine große virtualisierung machen es gibt es x für
für raspberry pi was a mox ich nicht bei py mox
hoxmox für raspberry pi also es gibt es für raspberry pi zumindest gab es da
mal eine preview version ich weiß nie ob es das wirklich final irgendwann mal
gegeben hat aber auf raspberry pi große virtualisierung wird da eh keiner machen
was ist bullshit selbstverständlich gab es es x für raspberry pi haben wir so
gerne im stream ausprobiert
also wirklich großartig virtualisierung werden die meisten leute wahrscheinlich
über die pine lassen ein paar container drauf laufen und das war es also ich
glaube ich habe ernsthaft noch nie irgendwie mit kvm oder so auf
raspberry pi vm laufen lassen ich jetzt gar nicht wozu
ich habe es nicht wirklich getestet und ehrlich gesagt weiß ich nicht wie viel Sinn es macht
virtual machine zu runnen mit den limited hardware kapazitäten von raspberry pi
also in diesem speziellen Fall wenn du einfach ein
home lab mit raspberry pi starten willst, gehst du trotzdem mit der linux distribution
in etwas wie ubuntu, skippe die virtual machine layer und deployier deine
workloads in containers instead, aber ich sehe keine andere Situation wo du
nicht mehr proxmox auf deinen home servers runnen möchtest, vielleicht noch eine und das ist wenn
du nicht primär in virtual machines bist, vielleicht spielst du manchmal mit
dem, aber dein Fokus ist mehr auf Storage und du möchtest eine mehr komplette
all-in-one-Solution für deinen Home Server haben, die leicht zu administrieren ist. Das ist die
dritte Gruppe von Systemen, die du benutzen könnt, in meiner Meinung, und das ist ein
NAS-System, so wie TrueNAS Scale, obwohl die originelle Idee von
TrueNAS schreibt bloß nicht im Freenance Forum, dass sie
gedenkt, das eventuell ohne ECC-RAM zu betreiben
System wie dieses ist, um ein NAS-System ohne ECC-RAM zu bauen, das kannst du auf keinen Fall machen, bloß nicht ohne ECC-RAM
da rasten sie alle aus
zum Beispiel habe ich vorhin ein Video über TrueNAS Scale gemacht, das sagt, dass das
vielleicht der perfekte Home Server-Operationssystem ist, weil es nicht
nur ein großartiger Storage Server mehr ist, übrigens kannst du noch einen
großartigen Storage Server bauen, mit dem du mehrere Hard Drives zusammenbundeln kannst
in einem redundanten und hohen Leistungspool und ihn als NAS-Machine benutzen, aber es
lässt dich auch leichter runnen und hunderts von
nötigen Applikationen und Packages, die du normalerweise auf einem Home Server runnst
Schau einfach mal auf das tolle TrueCharts-Projekt, das von der
Community of TrueNAS Scale, das lässt dich einfach neue Apps auf diesem NAS-System spinnen
mit nur ein paar Klicks, ich glaube, dass sie sogar eine neuere Version von dem veröffentlicht haben
und du kannst deine eigene privaten Storage mit Nextcloud oder
RunHome-Assistenten für SmartHome-Automation, ein Plex Media Server, es gibt so viele coole
Charts und...
Ja, unter der Haube?
Ist das immer noch BSD?
Spinners war BSD früher
Was ist denn TrueNAS? Ist das mittlerweile unter...
Okay, das ist Linux, ich hab nämlich mitgekriegt, dass die auf Linux umsteigen wollen
Also wahrscheinlich ist das unter der Haube auch irgendwelche Docker-Container
Was ist denn in deutscher? Die haben auch schon...
Ja, das hab ich auch gesucht, ich bin jetzt bei Android hängen geblieben
Aber auf der anderen Seite kannst du auch coole Dinge in TrueNAS Scale machen, die du nicht in Proxmox machen kannst
Also, was soll ich am Ende sagen? Es ist nicht immer einfach, zwischen all diesen verschiedenen Lösungen zu entscheiden
Für dich der Unterschied, TrueNAS, Android, ich hab TrueNAS Scale noch nie ausprobiert, ich kenne nur FreeNAS, da gab es diese ganze Container-Geschichte noch nicht, es waren noch irgendwelche BSD-Jails damals und das konntest du vergessen, keine Ahnung, hab ich noch nie ausprobiert
Können wir tatsächlich mal ausprobieren, hab ich noch nicht angeguckt
Dann kannst du anfangen andere Optionen zu erforschen, wie einen oder mehr Linux-Server zu runnen, wie Virtual-Maschinen mit verschiedenen Linux-Geschichten und Container-Geschichten ausprobieren, mit Docker und Kubernetes, du kennst wahrscheinlich alle diese Sachen aus meinen anderen Videos
Aber wenn du nicht so interessiert bist in diesen vorhandenen Dingen, kannst du auch mit dem NAS-System gehen, wie TrueNAS als dein Haupt-OS
Oder wenn du komplett verrückt bist wie ich und du willst noch mehr Workloads in deinem Home Lab runnen, dann benutze einfach beide
Warum haben die alle Kubernetes daheim, was machen die denn, ich mein das ist cool, don't get me wrong, was ist der wirklich Nutzen der quasi die Erhöhung an Komplexität rechtfertigt daheim
Du hast den alten Desktop nicht kopiert, nicht alles, nicht alles, nicht alles auf Neun, ich hab den alten Desktop ja noch laufen, ich hab auch alles auf ne Platte kopiert, bzw. mittlerweile aufs NAS kopiert, aber noch nicht alles rübergezogen
Lernen, Lernen ist gut, für Lernen finde ich das sinnvoll, aber zum Lernen würde ich nicht unbedingt meine Sachen daheim drauf laufen lassen
Aber ich glaube, das ist es für dieses Video, weil ich weiß, dass es wirklich viel war, obwohl ich nicht die Hälfte der anderen Optionen und Alternativen verwendet habe, die du auch auf deinem Home-Server runnen kannst
Ich denke, viele Leute in den Kommentaren werden nicht fragen, warum hast du Proxmox gewählt und warum hast du TrueNAS gewählt, was ist mit Open Media Vault oder XZPNG und so weiter
Ja, ich weiß, es gibt viele andere Plattformen und Systeme und Optionen, aber irgendwann musst du einfach aufhören, Alternativen zu suchen und einfach mit den Lösungen zu gehen, die dir gut funktionieren
Weil sonst endest du einfach hunderts von verschiedenen Systemen und Softwareen zu versuchen, die dir nicht gut funktionieren, die dir nicht gut funktionieren
Aber trotzdem, ein paar Optionen, die du auf deinem Home-Server runnst, machen wahrscheinlich mehr Sinn als andere und ich hoffe, dass dieses Video ein bisschen hilfreich war, um eine bessere Idee davon zu bekommen
Und ja, also das waren die besten Systeme und Plattformen, die ich so far in meinem Home-Server benutzt habe
Bitte sag mir, was sind deine Gedanken über diese Lösungen oder was andere, die du benutzt hast, vielleicht habe ich etwas wichtiges verpasst, glaube ich
Ja, Chet ist schon richtig, aber warum möchte man im Heimbereich Container migrieren und braucht dann irgendwie großartig Failover
Ich mein, seriously, es ist jetzt ja nicht so, als wäre es da irgendwie wahnsinnig schlimm, wenn das mal, sollte es wirklich, sollte wirklich komplett die Hardware abbrauchen
Wenn man diesen Fall abfangen will, ok, dann verstehe ich's, ja, meinetwegen
Wenn man wirklich einen kompletten Hardware-Fall irgendwie abdecken will, vielleicht, vielleicht
Aber, also wisst ihr, ganz ehrlich, wisst ihr, was ich machen würde?
Verangenehm, meine HP-Kiste hier hinten verreckt
Das Mainboard platzt irgendwie und Spannungswandler kaputt, lässt die NEMA reparieren
Verangenehm, meine Kiste ist komplett kaputt, morgens stehe ich auf, Bam, Kiste im Arsch
Wisst ihr, was ich da machen würde?
Ich würde einfach mir eine neue Kiste kaufen, das dauert zwar über Amazon dann zwei Tage, bis die da ist, ist doof
Und dann würde ich das Zeug restoren von der externen Platte
Eventuell reicht es sogar, wenn ich einfach die Platten umstecke, weil in Platten nichts passiert ist und nur das Mainboard verreckt ist oder was auch immer
Würde ich mir eine neue Kiste hinstellen, alten Platten reinhängen, starten, läuft wieder
Habe ich eben wirklich alle, alle ungünstigen Falle, habe ich dann zwei, drei Tage Downtime
Äh, damit kann ich im Heimbereich leben, dafür, dass ich mich so gut wie nicht um meinen Setup kümmern muss und es einfach funktioniert
Nee, keine Ahnung, hab ich noch nie gemacht
Das reicht mir immer im Heimbereich
Ganz im Ernst
Ansonsten, da ist auch nichts drauf, was ich jetzt unbedingt wirklich hundertprozentig bräuchte
Ich meine, es ist doof, wenn meine Heimautomatisierung nicht funktioniert, ja
Ist doof, wenn ich keine Backups mehr machen kann und solche Geschichten, doof, wenn ich nicht mehr auf mein Wiki zugreifen kann
Ist doof, wenn ich kein File zu irgendwas machen kann, ja
Aber mein Internet funktioniert
Das geht ja nicht, das geht nicht
Das Internet funktioniert und das ist erstmal das Wichtigste
WLAN funktioniert, muss auch nicht da drüber irgendwie gehen
Internet funktioniert, WLAN funktioniert
Der Rest geht im Zweifelsfall auch mal zwei, drei Tage ohne
Ich habe eine USB, ich habe eine USB-Modelle, die ich jetzt nicht mehr verwenden kann
Ich habe eine USB, ich habe eine USB mittlerweile wieder
Ich benutze aber kein klassisches RAID, ich benutze das, was Unraid da hat, mit ihrer komischen Parody-Geschichte
Ist ja kein klassisches RAID mit Synchronschreiben und sowas
Also ich habe dort ein RAID, also so ein Unraid-Ding über zwei Platten
Nee, über drei Platten, über drei Platten
Ohne Backup-Platte, fertig
Nee, noch nicht mal BTRFS, das glaube ich XFS
Oder das könnte sogar X4 sein
Hast du eine Fallback-Leitung? Hab ich nicht mehr
Ich hatte eine ganze Weile eine DSL-Fallback-Leitung
Aber die letzten Jahre über ist Vodafone so stable, bis halt auf die Sachen, wo es manchmal abkackt
Das manchmal abkackt und ja
Nee, nee, ich habe mich gerade gemutet
Und jetzt habe ich die abgestellt, ich habe keine Telekom-DSL-Leitung mehr
Da muss ich halt überlegen, ob es im Heimbereich den Aufwand alles rechtfertigt
Und ich habe es auch im professionellen Business-Umfeld schon erlebt, dass man sich mehr Probleme durch zusätzliche Komplexität eingefangen hat
Als durch echte Ausfälle dessen, was man mit Hochverfügbarkeitslösung abfackeln will
Also wenn du dann Hochverfügbarkeitsaufbau in Form von mehrere Application-Server, einen Loadbalancer davor, dann musst du den Loadbalancer ja noch klustern
Dann brauchst du noch eine Interconnect-Verbindung, dass du Split-Prain-Szenarien abfangen kannst und sowas
Also machst dann aus einer dicken Kiste, die alles abkann, mehrere Kisten mit Loadbalancer
Also die Komplexität ist um einiges höher
Und ich habe es auch wie gesagt im Business-Umfeld schon erlebt, dass man Probleme hatte, die es ohne Hochverfügbarkeit bzw. ohne diese zusätzliche Komplexität der Hochverfügbarkeit gar nicht gegeben hätte
Das darf man bei der ganzen Sache nicht außer Acht lassen
Also man kann Sachen hochverfügbar bauen, man kann Sachen ausfallsicher bauen
Das macht es nicht unbedingt immer unter dem Strich die Verfügbarkeitszahlen besser zwangsläufig
Schon gar nicht, wenn man das dann nicht ordentlich macht, weil man kann gerade bei einem Loadbalancer-Cluster oder bei Hochverfügbarkeitsaufbau bei Loadbalancer auch einiges verkacken
Also habe ich schon erlebt, dass du dann mehr Downtime hattest durch Hochverfügbarkeitsmaßnahmen, als hättest du die Hochverfügbarkeitsmaßnahmen einfach weggelassen
Gerade wenn du ein Loadbalancer-Cluster hast ohne Interconnect-Verbindung, dann ruckelt das Netzwerk, zwei sind der Meinung, sie sind Master und dann geht wieder nichts
Kann alles passieren
Kann man machen, kannst du machen
Du kannst auch gleich, du kannst ein Cluster-Filesystem nehmen, du kannst irgendwie so ein Netzwerk-Filesystem nehmen, es gibt da zig Varianten
Machen es in der Regel aber alles, für daheim zumindest unnötig komplex
Ich hatte beispielsweise mal einen Kollege auf der Arbeit, der hat Zev, glaube ich war das, ZevFS, wo man das auch immer ausspricht, daheim benutzt
Der hatte irgendwie einen, boah, total übertrieben, der hatte irgendwie einen, keine Ahnung, 78 Terabyte oder so, Zev
Das ist einfach nicht mal ein Cluster, sondern Zev-Verbund, keine Ahnung, was mit den Leuten da immer abgeht
Nicht Zev, Zev, ZevFS
Und auch nicht ZevFS, ich meine Zev, wie auch immer man das ausspricht, ZevFS
Ja, dafür ist es, dass es ja, Neues ausprobieren ist immer sinnvoll, aber ich würde halt nicht zwangsläufig jetzt da meine Live-Sachen daheim kaufen lassen
So Leute, ich geh jetzt ins Bett, wir sehen uns morgen, machts gut, bis denn, see you